Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbandes für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 14. Ausgabe. In der Reihe, wo wir schon viel über Wissenschaft gesprochen haben und teilweise viel ins Detail gegangen sind, teilweise viel uns auch auf der Metaebene bewegt haben. Wie zum Beispiel auch gleich ganz am Anfang in der ersten Ausgabe, als wir die Wissenschaftsgeschichte beleuchtet haben. Und im Verlauf des Gespräches ist uns auch bewusst geworden, dass das so mit der Geschichte eine sehr relative Angelegenheit ist und wir vor allem den bei uns verbreiteten europäischen Blick aufgehabt haben, der sicherlich auch sehr interessant war und ist. Trotz alledem reifte so die Erkenntnis, dass man diesen Blick vielleicht auch mal ein wenig erweitern sollte, denen der Planet ist ja rund und außerdem sehr groß und andere Leute haben auch kluge Sachen getan.
Und wollen von daher einen Blick nach Asien richten, wo sich ja nun auch über die Jahrhunderte und Jahrtausende eine Menge getan hat, was bei uns eben nicht so bereitliegt, wie das Wissen über Newton und andere Helden. Ja und um dieses Thema mal aufzurollen und die Wissenschaftsgeschichte aus einer anderen Perspektive zu betrachten, begrüße ich Dagmar Schäfer bei Forschergeist, hallo.
Sie sind beim Max-Planck-Institut für Wissenschaftsgeschichte hier in Berlin und dort eine von drei Direktorinnen von der Abteilung Artefakte, Handeln und Wissen.
Genau.
Das ist ja ein super Titel.
Ja.
Heißt was?
Ja vor allen Dingen heißt der zuerst einmal, dass ich mich sehr von der Perspektive der materiellen Kultur mit der Wissenschaftsgeschichte und Wissensgeschichte in Asien oder ich würde sogar sagen der nichteuropäischen oder nicht traditionellen Wissenschaftsgeschichte beschäftige. Und die beiden Begriffe Wissen und Handeln sind relativ wichtig in der asiatischen und insbesondere in der chinesischen intellektuellen Geschichte. Sie sind so eine Art Äquivalent zu einer Diskussion, die hier in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte in Europa auf die Diskrepanz, also auf die Unterscheidung von praktischen und theoretischen Wissen hinweist. Also diese Unterscheidung gibt es auf jeden Fall terminologisch nicht so in China. Und Wissen und Handeln sind dagegen eben sehr sehr wichtige Begriffe. Und um eben diesen anderen Ansatz in dem Titel der Abteilung ein bisschen hervorzubringen, eben diese Dreiheit von Artefakte, Wissen und Handeln im Titel der Abteilung.
Was sind dann die Artefakte?
Die Artefakte sind tatsächlich die materielle Kultur Asiens. Das heißt es gibt eine Tradition in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte China, die eigentlich meine Spezialität ist. Eben von Vornherein die materielle Kultur in der Interpretation der Entwicklung wissenschaftlichen und technischen Denkens, nicht auszuschließen. Und diese Tradition war viel weniger stark ausgeprägt in Europa. Das heißt also die ersten Wissenschaftshistoriker, die sich mit Asien beschäftigt haben, haben sehr viel materielle Kultur, Grabbeigaben, archäologische Funde, Technologie eben mit einbezogen in ihre Interpretationen. Um zu verstehen, wie hat sich das wissenschaftliche und technische Denken, Handeln in dieser Region entwickelt.
Ist das jetzt schon so viel anders als das in Europa gemacht wird?
Ja tatsächlich schon, weil in der europäischen Wissenschaftsgeschichte von Anfang an eigentlich davon ausgegangen wurde, dass das eine griechische, römische etc., also eine lange Tradition der Begrifflichkeit eigentlich von Wissen und Wissenschaft ist. Scientia zum Beispiel war einer der Begriffe, die man lange zurückverfolgen konnte und wo es hier eigentlich um theoretisches Wissen geht, um die Mathematisierung von Wissen, was ja natürlich irgendwo wichtig oder viele Wissenschaftshistoriker besonders der ersten Generation als das zentrale Merkmal der europäischen Entwicklung der Wissenschaften, der Naturwissenschaften und der Technik betrachtet haben. Und diese Begrifflichkeit gibt es einfach oder bzw. diese theoretischen Diskurse sind einfach anders in Asien, weil es diese Begriffe so nicht gibt.
Das heißt, das lief dann alles sehr viel praktischer ab und war ohne Theorie unterfüttert? Mehr so erfindungsgetrieben, kann man das so sagen?
Das ist tatsächlich einer der Dinge, die die Wissenschaftsgeschichte immer sehr stark beeinflusst hat, weil es natürlich eine gewisse Idee davon gibt, wie dieser Diskurs in Europa stattgefunden hat, hat man immer versucht, einen ähnlichen Diskurs in Asien zu finden. Aber tatsächlich sind eben nur die Begriffe andere gewesen. Den Diskurs gibt es auch und der beschäftigt sich eben zum Beispiel mit der Verbindung zwischen Wissen und Handeln und eben nicht zwischen Theorie und Praxis. Also die Begrifflichkeit ist anders. Doch die theoretische Diskussion gibt es tatsächlich schon. Aber um erst einmal zu zeigen, die ersten Wissenschaftshistoriker, der wichtigste davon ist Joseph Needham, der hat eben ganz stark auf Artefakte gesetzt, um zu zeigen, schaut mal hier, die Chinesen konnten zum Beispiel waren im Schiffsbau wesentlich weiter als wir, in der Navigation wesentlich weiter. Es gibt sogenannte Schattenstäbe, um zu zeigen, dass sehr früh schon eben laut chinesischer Wissenschaftsgeschichte eben schon seit dem Neolithikum der Himmel beobachtet wurde und darüber Daten gesammelt wurden.
Wohingegen die Diskurse schwerer zu finden waren. Oder auf jeden Fall sozusagen schwerer zu legitimieren war, dass diese Diskurse die gleichen Diskurse sind, die in Europa auch stattgefunden haben. Und deswegen stehen die Artefakte einfach so im Vordergrund.
Bevor wir richtig einsteigen und mal so versuchen, diese Wissenschaftsgeschichte Asiens von hinten ein wenig auszurollen, würde mich nochmal interessieren, wie das eigentlich so für Sie zum Thema geworden ist? Also wie ist so Ihre eigene Wissenschaftskarriere verlaufen, um dort zu landen, wo Sie jetzt sind?
Ich glaube wahrscheinlich, wie die meisten Wissenschaftshistoriker, die sich mit Asien beschäftigen, habe ich mit einem philologischen Studium angefangen, das heißt ich komme eigentlich aus der Sinologie, den Chinawissenschaften, wie es heute meistens heißt, aber es tatsächlich einfach das Erlernen der Sprache. Das zuerst, Sie können sich ja vorstellen, so was wie Wissenschaftsgeschichte in China ist nicht unbedingt etwas, was Ihnen einfällt, wenn Sie gerade Ihr Abitur gemacht haben, weil es das Thema tatsächlich im öffentlichen Diskurs ja kaum gibt. Jeder hat vielleicht schon mal von Newton oder Galileo gehört, aber wer hat schon mal von Shen Gua gehört oder Leuten wie Xu Guangqi, also den wichtigen Personen des wissenschaftlichen Denkens in Asien. Das heißt ich habe über die Sprache und das Studium der Kultur den Einstieg gefunden, hatte dann das unverschämte Glück, mit einem Professor zu arbeiten, einem Spezialisten in der Technikgeschichte, der sich sehr für die Seidenherstellung interessierte. Das ist ein wunderbares Thema, um so einen Einstieg in Wissenschaft und technisches Denken in dieser Region zu kriegen.
Weil Seide einfach omnipräsent ist in der chinesischen Kultur. Das heißt die Leute haben über Seide und Seidenherstellung nachgedacht und sie haben mit Seide gedacht. Oder mit der Entwicklung des Wurms zum Beispiel und der technischen Entwicklung. Das heißt darüber ist tatsächlich einfach ein Einstieg in das Thema da gewesen.
Und warum überhaupt China?
Warum überhaupt China?
Ich meine, auch Sinologie gehört ja jetzt nicht unbedingt zu den Top10 der Berufswünsche oder?
Inzwischen schon. Weil inzwischen kann man natürlich viel damit anfangen.
Okay.
Zu meiner Zeit war das Chinastudium tatsächlich wirklich eine sehr exzentrische Wahl.
Das war exotisch oder?
Ja eine relativ exotische Wahl. Aber es war, also normalerweise ist meine Antwort drauf und ich glaube es ist immer noch die richtige Antwort, es war eine Sprache, die ich nicht konnte und es war eine Kultur, die ich nicht kannte und es war eine Möglichkeit, tatsächlich völlig neu durchzustarten nach nach einer schulischen Karriere, die einen mit vielen Dingen in Verbindung bringt, aber eben nicht mit China oder chinesischer Sprache. Und das hat wahnsinnig viel Spaß gemacht. Also ich habe damals auch russisch angefangen, fand das aber nicht so spannend. Und das liegt aber natürlich auch daran, dass die russische Sprache wesentlich schwieriger ist als die chinesische.
Ist das so?
Ist das so, ja. Das ist so.
Aha.
Also die chinesische Sprache ist tatsächlich eine einfache Sprache. Die Aussprache ist relativ schwierig, da sie halt eben nicht so weit entfernt .. also sehr viel wichtiger in der Sprache ist, dass man das phonetisch beherrscht, aber tatsächlich ist die Sprache eine relativ einfache. Es gibt keine Deklinationen, es gibt keine Konjugation. Die Grammatik ist anders aufgebaut, aber sehr systematisch. Es gibt nicht sehr viele Ausnahmen. Also es ist tatsächlich eine relativ einfache Sprache.
Aber es gibt ja auch nicht nur ein Chinesisch?
Das stimmt. Das heißt die Phonetik, das heißt das Sprechen und das Hören und das Verstehen, das ist tatsächlich das schwierige. Man lernt Mandarin und muss sich dann mit den zahllosen, fast endlosen Dialekten rumquälen und tatsächlich auch verstehen lernen. Aber man hat natürlich den Vorteil, also ich gehöre noch zu einer Generation, die mit klassischem Chinesisch ausgebildet wurden und modernes Chinesisch kam dann tatsächlich erst in dem Auslandsaufenthalt in China dazu. Wir waren so die ersten Generationen, die tatsächlich länger in Asien studiert haben. Also man hat nach der Kulturrevolution, in der Kulturrevolution war es natürlich nicht möglich, so von Mitte der 60er bis Mitte der 70er Jahre überhaupt nach China zu gehen. Da gingen eigentlich die meisten Akademiker aus Europa nach Taiwan. Also das zweite China sozusagen zur Ausbildung.
Und so ab der Modernisierung von Deng Chao Ping in ein 80er Jahren konnte man dann tatsächlich in China studieren. Damals noch sehr kommunistisch. Und das heißt ich gehörte zu dieser Generation, wo man tatsächlich eben mit klassischem Chinesisch angefangen hat, aber dann in China modernes Chinesisch tatsächlich auch fließend gelernt hat. Die vorherige Generation...
Ist das dann so, als ob man erst Mittelhochdeutsch lernt und dann nach Deutschland kommt?
So ungefähr ja.
Also man redet wie so ein altes Buch.
Ja genau. Und das war tatsächlich einfach für mich der Aufhänger. Das heißt ich war in China, habe mich in das Land verliebt. Hätte auch nie gedacht, dass ich in Geschichte Ende, aber da hat es dann wirklich angefangen, Spaß zu machen. Erst einmal viel von der chinesischen Kultur kennenzulernen. Und über mehrere Umwege bin ich dann tatsächlich in der Geschichte gelandet.
Ich war jetzt noch nie in China, aber ich stelle mir das schon vor als so ein Land, wo man, wenn man dann wirklich mal vor Ort ist, schnell begreift, wie schwer diese Geschichte wiegt. Also durch die Architektur und vermutlich auch noch durch diverse andere Parameter. Das ist jetzt sagen wir mal so meine Illusion. Dass einem dann auch irgendwie auch erst gewahr wird, so die laufen jetzt hier nicht erst seit 200 Jahren am Strand entlang, sondern das riecht man geradezu, dass das irgendwie sehr viel tiefer verankert ist.
Ja das .. also Sie haben gerade Architektur angesprochen. Das ist natürlich so, man kommt nach China, besonders wenn Sie heute nach China kommen, davon ist nicht sehr viel übrig. Und das was Sie tatsächlich sehen und auch das was ich damals gesehen habe war entweder sehr verfallen oder inzwischen sieht es sehr viel eher wie Disneyland aus als tatsächlich also wunderschön restaurierte alte Gebäude. Aber es gibt würde ich sagen im Umgang der Leute ein sehr starkes Bewusstsein der Historizität ihrer eigenen Kultur. Also dass sie schon eine Kultur sind, die eben über Jahrhunderte, um nicht zu sagen über Jahrtausende, bestanden hat. So eine schöne Episode, die ich ab und zu mal erzähle, ist, als ich Student war habe ich an der Zhejiang Universität in Hangzhou studiert. Bin tatsächlich mit meinem wenigen Chinesisch dann aus dem Universitätskampus rausgegangen, habe einen Bauern gefragt ..
Also da rundherum waren Reisfelder. Habe einen Bauern gefragt, ob er mir etwas über den Reisanbau erzählen könnte und einer seiner ersten Sätze war tatsächlich, einfach zu sagen, wir haben eine Kultur, die über 1000 Jahre alt ist und es würde mindestens zwei Tage dauern, dir alle Einzelheiten zu erklären. Ich glaube nicht, dass er tatsächlich so viel über diese Kultur wusste, aber das Bewusstsein ist ganz einfach da. Dass sie eine lange kontinuierliche Tradition haben und ein großes Volk sind.
Woraus sich ja auch ein nicht unerheblicher Stolz ableitet. Das sieht man ja eigentlich alle Nase lang. Jetzt nicht nur bei so großen Veranstaltungen wie Olympia, sondern man ist sich dessen schon bewusst und es gibt schon so eine eigenständige Sicht auf die Welt, die dann von unserer sicherlich erheblich abweicht im Detail. Wenngleich wir ja, sagen wir mal, derzeit noch in so einer Technologieordnung sind, wo es mehr der Westen ist, der so ein bisschen die Nase vor zu scheinen hat. Ist schwer, das zu gewichten. Und Asien vor allem so als Produktionsstandort wahrgenommen wird.
Ja ich glaube, das sehen die Asiaten jetzt schon anders. Vor allen Dingen China möchte das ganz gerne anders sehen. Das sah man eben genau sehr gut bei der Olympiade. Dass auf der einen Seite natürlich betont wird, dass sie eigentlich das erste Land waren, das die vier großen Erfindungen tatsächlich hervorgebracht hat, also Papier, Kompass, Buchdruck und Schießpulver, die Bacon'schen Erfindungen, aber auch dass sie das Land sind, das mit großen Schritten in die Moderne hinein marschiert. Also während wir wahrscheinlich hier in Europa noch das Gefühl haben, China ist tatsächlich ein Produktionsstandort, sieht China sich eben als eine Nation, die auf Richtung Grundlagenforschung, Basisforschungen, wichtige neue naturwissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse nicht nur zumarschiert, sondern tatsächlich dort schon ist. Und das macht auch die Wissenschaftsgeschichte eben für sie so sehr interessant.
Man blickt zurück und man kann stolz darauf sein und man blickt nach vorne und kann nicht minder stolz darauf sein, was man in den letzten 20 oder 30 Jahren erreicht hat. Und das ist natürlich begründet, wenn ich soweit ausholen darf, auch sehr stark in der Geschichte des 19. und 20. Jahrhunderts, als China eben nicht so gut dastand. Und was China damals dachte, was sie sozusagen aus dieser schlechten Position herausholen kann, also denke an Opiumkriege, 1. und 2. Weltkrieg, als die erstens einmal die große Nation China dann tatsächlich einfach auch zerfiel. Es also kein einheitliches Territorium gab. Aber als auch eben die britischen, die französischen, die russischen Mächte in China einmarschierten und sich eben nahmen, was sie wollten. Die Japaner, ich glaube das ist auch den Europäern bekannt, dass es hier eben ..
Reibung gibt.
Ja immer wieder Spannungen gibt, genau. Dass in dieser Periode, was hat China weiter nach vorne gebracht, der Kommunismus, Maoismus, aber auch eben in die Moderne hinein mit wissenschaftlicher und technischer Entwicklung. Und deswegen ist eben Wissenschaft und Technik für China eben ein großes Politikum.
Weil es jetzt im Prinzip auch Ausdruck des Wiedererstarkens ist, nachdem man sich mal 100-200 Jahre der Nachlässigkeit geleistet hat?
Absolut genau. Und weil man halt eben diese Kontinuität trotzdem es mag mal Höhen und Tiefen geben, aber es gibt eine Kontinuität der Kultur.
Dann blättern wir doch vielleicht mal ein bisschen zurück, um das besser zu verstehen. Ist ja immer schwierig, von irgendetwas einen Anfang zu finden, vor allem um so weiter man zurück geht, umso schlechte ist es natürlich dokumentiert. Und hängt dann letztlich auch sozusagen von der Forschung ab. Aber ab wo kann man denn sagen, dass die Region und ich meine, wir werden jetzt wahrscheinlich viel von China sprechen, aber nicht nur und wir sehen jetzt auch wirklich glaube ich mal alles was jetzt nicht im unmittelbaren europäischen und arabischen Einfluss ist. Also das ist so ein bisschen so jetzt auch unsere Gedankengrenze. Dass der arabische Raum, der extrem mit Griechenland und Europa lange Zeit verbunden war und irgendwo wird es da sicherlich auch eine Nahtstelle nach Indien geben, aber im Prinzip so von Indien bis Japan das ist so das was wir meinen, wenn wir Asien sagen?
Ja, also man geht da relativ weit zurück. Vor allen Dingen wenn man heute über Wissenschaftsgeschichte in einer größeren Perspektive spricht, also eine Wissenschaftsgeschichte, die sich eben nicht nur mit den Naturwissenschaften beschäftigt, sondern mit dem, das Deutsche macht ja da eine Unterscheidung im Gegensatz zum Englischen, also mit Science and Humanities, mit Naturwissenschaften und den Geisteswissenschaft. Und man fängt da relativ früh an bei Dingen, wie der Entwicklung der Sprache, Himmelsbeobachtung, Meteorologie und dergleichen. Und da finden Sie natürlich in Asien einige Hochkulturen, die schon einiges dazu zu sagen haben. Ob Sie jetzt von Mesopotamien ausgehen, wo die Kultur der, ja eigentlich sehr früh die Keilschrift hervorgebracht hat.
Man spricht dann zweitens von so indischen Kultur, die sich zusammen mit den Kulturen in Südostasien und den Kulturen in dem heutigen Raum von China um die Flüsse gebildet haben. Also dem Mekong, dem gelben Fluss und jetzt fällt mir tatsächlich leider der …
Ja der indische fällt mir leider nicht ein.
Yangtse.
Der Ganges.
Ja genau. Die sich um diese Flüsse herum tatsächlich angesiedelt haben. Da findet man natürlich auch sehr viele Zeugnisse von eben früher Schriftkultur, aber eben auch von technischer Entwicklung, Hausbau, Schiffsbau, Keramikherstellung. Also alles Dinge, die man heute tatsächlich in die Wissenschaftsgeschichte hineinzählt. Also früher hat man eine sehr starke Unterscheidung zwischen Wissenschafts- und Technikgeschichte gemacht, das macht man heute eigentlich nicht mehr so. Das heißt Sie fangen ganz früh eigentlich in der Archäologie an und dann ist es natürlich eben sehr stark davon abhängig, wie es tatsächlich einfach Dokumente in den verschiedenen Regionen gibt. Es gibt also im nahen Osten eine große Periode eigentlich zwischen diesen archäologischen Funden bis zum 6./7. Jahrhundert, wo es nicht viel Schrifttum gibt. Also relativ wenig Forschung über Naturwissenschaft und Technikgeschichte.
In Indien sieht es noch dramatischer aus. Also besonders, wenn man über diesen Subkontinent nachdenkt, weil der war ja nicht immer von den gleichen Mächten beherrscht. Es gibt eigentlich nur eine Kontinuität in der Hochschrift, also im Sanskrit, aber es gibt natürlich viele andere Sprachen, die auch gesprochen oder bzw. in denen auch geschrieben wurde, wo es einfach keine Zeugnisse gibt. Auch aufgrund der Kolonialisierung, vieles ist tatsächlich auch zerstört worden. In Südostasien sieht es fast noch schlimmer aus. Ich denke, viele Hörer werden Angkor Wat kennen. Das heißt es gibt relativ viele …
Kambodscha.
Ja Kambodscha. Viele archäologische Funde, aber im Schrifttum ist es tatsächlich auch sehr schwierig. Und wenn es Schrifttum gibt, dann gibt es das meistens entweder in der Kolonialperiode oder wenn Sie früher gehen, dann auf Chinesisch. Weil diese Kulturen eben sehr viel Kontakt auch mit China hatten und dann eben diese Sprache benutzt haben. Und dann gibt es die chinesische Kultur und es gibt relativ viel Forschung zu Japan. Das muss man tatsächlich sagen, aber auch da sehr stark auf die letzten 400-500 Jahre bezogen. Und China ist tatsächlich die Kultur, die einfach über 2000-3000 Jahre eben eine Kontinuität nachweisen kann. Also eine Dokumentation, die man tatsächlich hat.
Ja 3000 Jahre das fällt ja dann schon auch voll parallel zu den Entwicklungen Ägyptens mit rein. Also quasi, wenn wir jetzt in Europa zurückdenken an wissenschaftliche Errungenschaften, dann startet es ja irgendwie in Ägypten und natürlich auch in Griechenland in diesen Zeiten und im Prinzip hat sich eigentlich zur selben Zeit das auch in Asien angefangen, zu entwickeln. Nur dass man jetzt keine Pyramiden gebaut hat.
Ja dafür hat man zum Beispiel große Gräber gebaut. Ein Grab, dass man zum Beispiel kennt ist das des Qin Shihuang di, das ist etwa 1000 Jahre später. Aber es gibt eben vorher schon eine massive Grabkultur, von der wir wissen, dass es also großes architektonisches Wissen gab. Das Straßen gebaut wurden, dass Kanäle oder hydraulische Anlagen hergestellt wurden. Das heißt Sie finden da tatsächlich eine zeitliche Übereinstimmung.
Auch mit der römischen Entwicklung dann?
Ja genau. Und da wissen wir ja zum Beispiel auch, dass über Zentralasien viele Kontakte bestanden zwischen der Han-Dynastie und den Römern gab es zum Beispiel einen sehr regen Handel an Seiden und an Färbemitteln zum Beispiel. Da haben wir dann tatsächlich auch schon Dokumente darüber, dass miteinander kommuniziert wurde. Und das geht dann tatsächlich eben zum Beispiel auch in die Gandhara Kultur hinein. In indische Regionen. Alexander der Große sagt Ihnen was, der die ganze Region ja bereist hat. Also hier sind einfach Dokumente da, mit denen man arbeiten kann.
War denn die Seidenstraße dann sozusagen das erste Bindeglied zwischen diesen beiden?
Ja, Seidenstraße ist ja eigentlich ein Begriff, der von Ferdinand von Richthofen erst im 19. Jahrhundert geprägt wurde. Und Seidenstraße ist ja eigentlich ursprünglich eine Verbindung, die zwischen China und Indien und nicht zwischen China und Europa oder der Han-Dynastie und eben dem römischen Reich hergestellt wurde. Und das ist eine Handelsstrecke, die aus verschiedenen Abschnitten bestand, die eben von verschiedenen Handelsvölkern zwischendurch immer wieder bespielt wurde. Und da kann man tatsächlich sagen, wenn man das so sieht, dann fängt das in dieser Zeit an. Oder auf jeden Fall fängt die Dokumentation in dieser Zeit an. Und da sind eben ganz viele Dokumente haben zum Beispiel etwas mit Medizin zu tun, mit Himmelsbeobachtungen. In der Perspektive auch Religion und dergleichen. Das ist für eine Wissenschaftsgeschichte sehr interessant. Einige von Ihnen werden vielleicht schon mal Dunhuang gehört haben, das ist eine Oase, die eben noch im heute chinesischen Territorium an der Taklamakan-Wüste liegt.
Und da hat man zum Beispiel viele Dokumente einfach aufbewahrt, weil man sie in Hüllen eingeschlossen hat. Und da finden Sie zum Beispiel auch die Verbindungsglieder zwischen europäischen Kulturen, persischen oder bzw. dann frühen Kulturen des nahen Ostens und indischen Kulturen. Weil die ja eben viele Handelsvölker oder Handelsstraßen zusammengelaufen sind.
Lassen Sie uns vielleicht mal den unmittelbaren Kontakt zu Europa außen vor und schauen wir einfach mal, was sich quasi in Asien jetzt selbst entwickelt hat. Auch jetzt aus dem Gespräch mit Frau Voigt erinnere ich noch so, dass es ja überhaupt in der Gesellschaft den Begriff der Wissenschaft natürlich so am Anfang erst mal gar nicht gab. Es gab halt so Einzelkämpfer, viel wurde über irgendwie philosophische Dinge auch gebracht. Ein Wissenschaftler war ja in der Regel ja auch ein Allroundtalent. War das denn jetzt in China auch so von so einzelnen Personen so stark geprägt, die hervorgetreten sind und das Bild des Wissenschaftlers überhaupt erst hervor gebracht haben oder gab es dieses Bild so nie?
Genau.
Also womit fing es an? Also hat man einfach nur so erfunden und es war gar nicht organisiert und es waren nur so Einzelkämpfer oder hat man sich von Vornherein zusammen getan und hat gesagt, wir müssen jetzt hier mal unsere Technik verbessern?
Also es gibt natürlich nicht den Wissenschaftler, wie Frau Voigt eben auch schon gesagt haben wird, aber es gibt viele Gelehrte in China. Man sagt eigentlich, dass wenn man so die Gesellschaftsstrukturen anschaut, dann fängt das mit einem Feudalherrentum, Aristokratie an und was China so besonders macht, dass es im 10. Jahrhundert so eine Art Meritokratie, also eine auf Prüfungen basierende Gesellschaft sich entwickelt, wo also die Elite sich dadurch rekrutierte, dass sie eben Prüfungen durchlaufen musste. Aber Gelehrtentum von Anfang an eben sehr, soweit man in das dynastische China zurückblicken kann, also ab dem 2. Jahrhundert vor Christus, vielleicht noch ein bisschen früher, die Leute, die lesen konnten, halt immer schon sehr wichtig waren.
Und diese Gelehrten beschäftigen sich natürlich mit dem, was wir heute für Wissenschaft oder Technik halten. Und von diesen Leuten wissen wir, weil sie a) kanonische Werke geschrieben haben. Eines was zum Beispiel allgemein bekannt ist, wobei man nicht genau weiß, wer der Autor ist, das ist das Buch der Wandlungen, das I Ging oder das Buch der Dokumente, die alle in dieser Periode vor dem dynastischen China entstanden sind. Und die sich eben mit Dingen beschäftigen, wie Naturbeobachtung, wie laufen die Jahreszeiten ab, was sehe ich am Himmel, wie gehe ich mit Nahrungsmitteln um etc. Landwirtschaft, solche Themen sind halt dort angesprochen. Nicht unbedingt so wie wir sie heute verpackt wissen. Aber tatsächlich gibt es diese Themen halt in dem Schrifttum.
Im Prinzip so kleine Enzyklopädien. So Sammlungen des Wissens.
Genau. Und eigentlich sind es historische Werke. Also es sind so was wie Geschichtsschreibungswerke oder philosophische Werke, wie man eben einen Aristoteles ausschreibt. Nur bei den meisten dieser Werke muss man davon ausgehen im chinesischen Kontext, dass sie nicht nur einen Autor haben, sondern dass sie Sammlungen sind. Und dann gibt es ab dem 2. Jahrhundert vor Christus immer eine dynastische Geschichtsschreibung. Das heißt die Dynastien haben immer ihre Geschichten aufgeschrieben. Und die nächste Dynastie hat sie dann meistens umgeschrieben, um sich zu legitimieren. Aber in diesen Geschichtsschreibungen, also wenn ich jetzt relativ weit ausgeholt habe, aber da gibt es Biografien drin. Und diese Biografien sind eben über wichtige Personen. Und das können Philosophen sein. Das sind natürlich ganz oft einfach Herrscher. Leute, die politisch oder sozial relevant waren, Künstlern. Und da gibt es eben auch bestimmte Gruppen, Philosophengruppen, die sich sehr viel mit Themen beschäftigt haben, die wir als naturwissenschaftlich oder technisch bezeichnen würden, wie die Daoisten.
Und das ist so eine Gruppe, die eben sehr interessiert an Naturbeobachtung war. Daoismus ist glaube ich heute auch so ein bisschen ein Begriff. Da gibt es dieses YingYang-Modell, die Idee eine relativ holistische Weltvorstellung, wenigstens wenn man von der Hauptrichtung des Daoismus ausgeht. Und diese Leute haben eben tatsächlich zum Beispiel sich viel mit Alchimie beschäftigt, mit dem Körper, mit Jahreszeiten, mit Zeitberechnung und dergleichen. Da gibt es dann einzelne Werke eher, als dass man sagen kann, es gibt einzelne Figuren. Und richtige so Helden gibt es, oder so eine Heldengeschichtsschreibung der Wissenschaftler gibt es eben erst im 19. Jahrhundert, basierend auf diesen Biografien. Und die Personen, die man dann findet, sind meistens Personen, die irgendwas mit der Regierung zu tun hatten, mit Politik zu tun hatten ab dem 7./8./9./10. Jahrhundert.
Also Leute, die zum Beispiel Brückenbau gemacht haben. Die sich mit Deichen beschäftigt haben. Die architektonisch tätig waren. Die den Himmel beobachtet haben und neue astronomische Theorien aufgestellt haben und dann in diesen Biografien verewigt sind. Die sind aber tatsächlich nicht darin gelandet, weil sie berühmte Wissenschaftler waren, sondern weil sie wichtige Staatsmänner waren.
Sind denn die ganzen Entwicklungen, von denen wir jetzt gerade reden, so reine innerchinesische Entwicklungen oder ist das eine Entwicklung, die auch in anderen Regionen Asiens parallel oder in Zusammenarbeit mit stattfand?
Sie ist auf jeden Fall würde ich sagen Indikativ dafür, dass in anderen Regionen ähnliche Ideen der Geschichtsschreibung wichtig waren. Das heißt, wenn Sie in den nahen Osten gehen, dann haben Sie natürlich eine sehr religiös geprägte Geschichtsschreibung in bestimmten Perioden und da finden Sie dann eben die Biografien der besonders wichtigen religiösen Führer oder tatsächlich der besonders wichtigen politischen Führer mit einem religiösen Hintergrund. Die aber eben sich auch mit der Deutung des Himmels beschäftigt haben. Oder die sich besonders für griechische Mythologie oder dergleichen interessiert haben. Das heißt auch hier finden Sie nicht dieses Bild des Wissenschaftlers, Sie finden eher die sozial oder politisch relevante Person, die sich eben auch damit beschäftigt hat, was wir heute als Wissenschaft oder Technik bezeichnen würden.
Und in Indien ist es tatsächlich sehr kompliziert. Also Sie finden ebenso eben eine sehr stark textbasierte und nicht autorenbasierte Identifikation. Das heißt es wird mehr Wert darauf gelegt, dass es einen bestimmten Text gibt, wohingegen der Autor oft in den Hintergrund rückt.
Aber was jetzt die konkreten technischen Fortschritte, die dort erzielt wurden, betrifft kann man schon sagen, dass China schon so ein bisschen die Nase vorn hatte?
Es sieht auf jeden Fall manchmal so aus ja.
Manchmal nicht immer?
Ja, also es sieht vor allen Dingen deswegen so aus, weil tatsächlich darüber geschrieben wurde. Sie finden zum Beispiel im 2. Jahrhundert nach Christus ein sogenanntes Carpenter's Manual, also ein Handbuch der Schreinerei, in denen genau beschrieben wird, wie ein Webstuhl mit einem Musterturm aussieht. Also das muss man sich so ähnlich vorstellen wie einen Jacquard-Webstuhl, das heißt da sitzt oben auf dem Turm jemand, der die Fäden zieht, um die Muster zu kreieren. Das ist eine relativ komplizierte Maschine, mit auch nicht einer ganz einfachen Mechanik, die diese Person, warum auch immer, so wichtig fand, dass sie eben angefangen hat, ein Traktat darüber zu verfassen. Es gibt aber eben auch Traktate, die über Goldfische oder über Peonien oder dergleichen oder wie brüte ich die Enteneier aus oder dergleichen, über solche Dinge eben über die Jahrhunderte berichten.
Und das haben Sie bei vielen anderen Kulturen haben Sie einfach die Dokumentation nicht. Also es gibt ja immer so gewisse Perioden, in denen einfach sehr viel zerstört wurde. Oder wo andere Themen einfach wichtig waren. Im nahen Osten haben Sie zum Beispiel, im heute nahen Osten, in diesen Kulturen haben Sie halt einfach Perioden, in denen die Mechanik sehr wichtig war und es gibt dann einige Werke, die darüber berichten und dann gibt es Perioden, in denen entweder solche Werke nicht geschrieben wurden oder die sind nicht mehr da. Sie wurde nicht rezipiert.
Na gut, aber worauf ich hinaus wollte ist, hat alles nur in China stattgefunden oder lässt sich sozusagen in Japan ein ganz ähnlicher Trend, aber immer nur am Rockzipfel Chinas oder mehr oder weniger zeitgleich feststellen? Also wie muss man sich sozusagen die Gewichte vorstellen der Entwicklung?
Ich glaube, das ist bei vielen Dingen, wenn man heute wirklich tatsächlich eine bessere Dokumentation hat, man keine solchen Aussagen machen kann. Dass irgendjemand die Nase irgendwo wirklich vorne hatte. Man spricht heute in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte ja auch oft von der multiple origin theory. Also es gibt eben viele Ursprünge. Also es gibt ja eigentlich auch nicht mehr die Idee davon, dass es so was wie eine lineare Entwicklung gibt. Also dass Wissen sich immer akumuliert hat. Sondern es kommt halt Wissen auf und dann geht es verloren und dann kommt es wieder auf und irgendwann hat es Relevanz und dann hat es eben tatsächlich keine Relevanz. Und es gibt natürlich auch Traditionen in der Geschichtsschreibung. Japan zum Beispiel stellte sich sehr oft so dar, als würde es eben sehr viel von China übernehmen und nicht selber entwickeln, weil sie halt eben die chinesische Kultur in Perioden eben als sehr wichtig empfunden haben und sie wahrscheinlich eben auch war.
Es gibt zum Beispiel im 10. oder 11. Jahrhundert und im 16. und 17. Jahrhundert hat Japan unheimlich viele wissenschaftlich und technisch interessante Werke massenhaft nach Japan verschiffen lassen und hat dann angefangen, diese zu rezipieren und völlig neu zu entwickeln. Hat aber immer sehr viel Wert darauf gelegt, also die Gelehrten dieser Zeit haben sehr viel Wert darauf gelegt, immer wieder sich selber an dieser chinesischen Tradition zu verankern und dadurch entsteht natürlich auch für den Historiker einfach das Gefühl, dass hier, wie Sie so schön sagten, Japan so ein bisschen am Rockzipfel von China gehangen hat. Aber wenn Sie genauer hinsehen, dann sehen Sie halt, sie haben eine Entwicklung tatsächlich gesehen, die  in China stattgefunden hat, haben sich dann aber völlig anders entwickelt und haben auch ganz ganz besondere Entwicklungen oder Neuerungen tatsächlich auch vorgebracht, die in China zum Beispiel nie stattgefunden haben.
Okay, also es gab da auf jeden Fall eine breit angelegte Entwicklung mit gegenseitiger Einflussnahme, aber es lässt sich auch festhalten, China war schon nicht dominant, aber zumindest ausgesprochen wichtig und kann vor allem im Wesentlichen so alle großen Entwicklungen auch so aus sich selbst heraus belegen?
Ja. Das kann man so sagen. Das gleiche könnten wahrscheinlich auch Wissenschaftler, die sich besser im nahen Osten auskennen, auch sagen für bestimmte Perioden. Und man könnte tatsächlich sagen, es gibt so ein bisschen eine Abwechslung. Also mal ist die eine Kultur stärker, mal ist die andere Kultur stärker. Der arabische zum Beispiel war auch lange in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte eine der besser erforschten Regionen außerhalb Europas, weil halt eben im Mittelalter sehr sehr viele Ideen aus dem arabischen Raum bis nach Europa gelangt sind. Und da halt eben Europa extrem beeinflusst haben.
Jetzt ist ja die Menschheit so in seinen großen Phasen von Jäger- und Sammlertum bis hin zum agrarbasierten sesshaften Menschen und dann irgendwann eben zu diesem vollständig technologiegetriebenen Wesen durchgegangen. Wann haben sich so diese Schritte in China entwickelt? Also mir scheint ja, dass dieses sesshafte, was ja vor allem so in Mesopotamien überhaupt erstmalig entwickelt hat, auch relativ schnell in Asien Fuß gefasst zu haben?
Das ist tatsächlich eine schwere Frage. Man kann auf jeden Fall sagen, dass .. also es gibt im chinesischen Raum mindestens drei, wenn nicht sogar fünf, Kulturen, die also die man so als Ursprungskulturen von China bezeichnet. Die sich irgendwo grob zwischen 5000 und 1000 oder 2000 vor Christus bewegen. Und daraus ist dann im 2. Jahrhundert vor Christus so eine Art dynastische Mythologie gemacht worden. Also dass man sozusagen in die Vergangenheit reinguckt und sagt, da gab es einen Herrscher und ach da gab es davor aber auch noch einen und dann gab es noch einen davor. Das politische System wird also nach hinten transferiert. Und da finden Sie tatsächlich eigentlich, dass fast ganz Zentralasien irgendwann auf die chinesische Kultur ganz stark gewirkt hat.
Also dass Sie da zum Beispiel Einflüsse finden, man hat zum Beispiel vor zwei Monaten – man könnte sagen – Nordeuropäer in Zentralasien bei Samarkand gefunden, die tatsächlich einfach nicht chinesischen oder asiatischen Ursprungs waren, die sich in dieser Region aufgehalten haben. Also da können Sie nicht davon ausgehen, dass die chinesische Kultur da tatsächlich einen Ursprung hat, sondern sie ist eine Vermischung von verschiedenen.
Ja gut, wie aber ja wahrscheinlich alle auch irgendwo.
Genau.
Worauf ich ein bisschen hinaus wollte ist, wann lässt sich sozusagen so ein Trend ablesen, dass die Kultur sich eben auch über ihren wissenschaftlichen Fortschritt über Technik definiert hat?
Auf jeden Fall in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte oft als solches bezeichnet ist die Periode zwischen 10. und 12. Jahrhundert, als Gelehrte an die Macht kommen. Als Leute, die sich über Bücherwissen, über mehr Wissen definieren und ihre Stellung darüber definieren.
Also schon die eingangs erwähnte Meritokratie.
Genau, die Sung-Dynastie. Die sich tatsächlich damit beschäftigt hat. Das ist aber allerdings auch die schwächste Dynastie, die China jemals beherrscht hat. Das heißt das ist die Periode, wo die Gelehrten an der Macht waren, und China militärisch wirklich unheimlich schwach war und sich eigentlich nur dieses Gebiet zwischen dem Yangtse, also zwischen dem gelben Fluss und später sogar zwischen dem langen Fluss und was man heute so die Nordgrenze von Vietnam bezeichnen würde, in dieser Region tatsächlich aufhalten konnte. Und da gibt es, da sind sozusagen die Haupterfindungen dokumentiert worden. Schießpulver, der Buchdruck ist plötzlich unheimlich prominent geworden, obwohl er wahrscheinlich schon im 7. Jahrhundert erfunden wurde oder bzw. wirklich kommerzialisiert wurde, ist es in dieser Periode, dass Buchdruck wirklich richtig nach vorne schießt.
Dass es plötzlich Werke über alle möglichen Themen gibt, wie gesagt die Entenzucht.
Also der Buchdruck war in China schon im 7. Jahrhundert dran?
Ja das weiß man heute eigentlich ganz klar, dass die im 7. Jahrhundert eigentlich mit Blockdruck schon sehr weit operiert haben. Vor allen Dingen durch den Buddhismus auch, der das natürlich auch, also es gibt da ganz sicherlich eine Verbindung, dass das nicht eigentlich ursprünglich in China prominent war, sondern über diesen indisch-asiatischen Raum sich tatsächlich ausgebreitet und durchgesetzt hat.
Und dann hat es nochmal 700 Jahre gedauert, bis die Europäer nachgezogen haben?
Ja ich meine der Buchdruck in Europa, Gutenberg, das sind ja die Blocklettern. Und da gibt es heute weiß man, dass es tatsächlich im 8. Jahrhundert in Korea ein Dokument gibt, wo der Blockdruck mit beweglichen Lettern tatsächlich schon beschrieben wird. Nur in China hat das niemand benutzt, weil das auch niemand interessant fand, und weil das auch tatsächlich völlig ineffizient ist für die chinesische Sprache, wenn Sie bedenken, dass hier eben nicht mit einem Alphabet gearbeitet wird, sondern mit Schriftzeichen bzw. Mit einer Verbindung von phonetischen und ja man nennt die glottografische Elemente, also dass mit Symbolen gearbeitet wird und dass man die nicht so einfach zusammensetzen kann, weil die natürlich immer ein bisschen größer oder ein bisschen kleiner sind, damit sie in die Form des Schriftzeichens reinpassen.
Und das kann man mit beweglichen Lettern zwar auch machen, bedeutet aber, dass man unheimlich viele einzelne Schriftzeichen produzieren muss und das lohnt sich einfach nicht. Das Alphabet hat ja nur 26.
Also die Sprache selbst war sozusagen, die Schriftsprache selbst war nicht so gut geeignet für den Buchdruck, aber die Technik hätte man schon hinbekommen?
Für den mit Blocklettern ja. Aber für den Blockdruck war es zum Beispiel exzellent geeignet. Und das war auch tatsächlich ist der Buchdruck da eben ganz anders abgelaufen. Das heißt man hat einfach die Blöcke für den Buchdruck gemacht und dann hat man die Blöcke behalten und dann sozusagen on Demand einfach so gedruckt, wie das Buch nachgefragt wurde. Wenn Sie einmal die Blöcke haben, können Sie ja immer so viele Kopien drucken.
Also Blöcke im Sinne von für eine ganze Seite sozusagen?
Genau, ja oder für ein ganzes Buch. Und die Verlage haben auch tatsächlich diese Blöcke aufbewahrt und haben dann einfach produziert soweit sie das brauchen. Das heißt sie wissen auch in der Regel bei diesen Büchern nicht, wie viel, Sie können keine Auflage bestimmten. Weil das wurde halt so lange verwendet, bis halt der Block nicht mehr verwendbar war.
Nicht schlecht. Also Printing on Demand, was jetzt irgendwie hier erst in den letzten Jahren Einzug gehalten hat, gab es also schon da vor irgendwie über tausend Jahren.
Absolut.
Bemerkenswert. Das heißt diese Sung-Dynastie ist schon interessant. Also militärisch schwach, weil sie sich eigentlich auf ihre Stärken berufen wollten? Aber schon technisch auch einen Fortschritt gemacht, der sicherlich ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht dann üblicherweise ja auch so ein Anstieg von Luxus sagen ich mal beinhaltet, der die Städte besser funktionieren lässt. Hat das dann sozusagen dazu geführt, dass man wenn man jetzt sagt, wir kämpfen aber jetzt nicht mehr so viel, weil wir müssen nachdenken, dass sie dann deswegen irgendwie niedergegangen ist die Dynastie?
Ich glaube es war eine etwas, man könnte vielleicht sagen, eine sehr intelligente Überlegung. Und zwar in dieser Periode ist tatsächlich einfach der Frieden eingekauft worden. Das hat China ja immer schon sehr gerne gemacht. Das ist auch, wenn Sie die Periode anschauen, in der Tang-Dynastie, in der es zum Beispiel auch viele wissenschaftliche und technische Entwicklung gibt, weil in der Periode zum Beispiel viel mit Indien oder viele Kontakte mit Indien und dem jetzigen arabischen, also nahen Osten Raum, tatsächlich besteht. Also da wissen wir zum Beispiel, dass viele Astronomen von Hof zu Hof gereist sind. Die Tang-Dynastie hat auch eine viel weitere Ausdehnung nach Zentralasien rein. Aber in der Sung-Dynastie, als die Gelehrten an die Macht kamen, haben sie tatsächlich gesagt, es ist eigentlich günstiger, sich den Frieden einzukaufen, anstatt Waffen herzustellen. Oder anstatt halt eben die Armee von A nach B zu schicken.
Also im Sinne von mit Handel.
Mit Handel. Man nennt das mit Tribut bezahlen. Das ist zum Beispiel auch etwas, was die dann nachfolgende mongologische Dynastie, die Jin-Dynastie oder die vielleicht einigen in der Geschichte als Pax Mongolica bekannt ist. Das heißt in der Periode, als eigentlich die verschiedenen Kanate ganz Zentralasien unter sich aufgeteilt haben, in der zum Beispiel astronomisches Wissen und mathematisches Wissen einen unheimlichen Schub, also in ganz Eurasien, einfach vorwärts gemacht hat, weil eben wirklich von der Mittelmeerküste, vielleicht sogar noch weiter, bis nach Japan viel Transfer stattfand. Weil es eben ein politisch vereinigtes Gebiet war. Oder auf jeden Fall eins, in dem diese verschiedenen Kanate sehr stark in Verbindung miteinander standen. Und in dieser Periode gibt es dann halt einfach andere Disziplinen, die zum Tragen kommen. Navigation zum Beispiel.
Mathematik ganz stark. Da gibt es dann eben auch eine Vermischung von Traditionen. Und da gibt es zum Beispiel auch die Araber bringen sehr viel Mechanik nach Asien, die da gar nicht bekannt war. Aber in diesem 10. bis 11. oder 12. Jahrhundert da gibt es eben viel Verschriftlichung und Ideen von, wie entwickelt sich ein Organismus, welche Zusammensetzung hat der Körper. Eine kosmologische Sicht entwickelt sich. Also es gibt eben einfach andere Bereiche, die im Fokus stehen.
Was haben denn die Chinesen so über die Welt gedacht? Also ich meine so der Klassiker in unserem europäischen Geschichtsbild ist natürlich so, dass es dieses Dogma gab, die Erde ist eine Scheibe und dann fällt man da irgendwie runter und überhaupt ist da so eine Kuppel drüber und dahinter ist dann irgendwie Gott. War ja da auch irgendwie alles voll religionsdurchsetzt und die Wissenschaft hatte ja nun gerade auch so in den Dark Ages das Problem, dass sie irgendwie gegen dieses Mantra der Gottsicht irgendwie überhaupt nicht ankamen mit ihren Erkenntnissen, weil das widersprach halt einfach den Aussagen der Kirche und bedrohte damit ihre Macht und dann war das halt irgendwie alles doof. Ich bin weit davon entfernt, zu verstehen, wie das mit Religion eigentlich überhaupt funktioniert in China, aber welchen Status hatten denn quasi diese wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse? Was war denn sozusagen das Ergebnis der Beobachtung der Sterne? Also ich vermute mal, es dürfte sich auch hier mehr oder weniger parallel zu Ägypten.
Also es gab ja auch in Ägypten schon welche, die verstanden hatten, dass die Erde rund sein müsste, das hat dann eben lange gedauert bis sich das durchgesetzt hat, aber es wurde im Prinzip ja schon beobachtet. Was war die Sicht auf die Erde in China? Was dachte man, was die Welt ist und hatte das irgendwas mit Religion dann zu tun?
Ja und nein. Es hatte nichts mit Religion zu tun, aber es hatte sehr viel mit Politik zu tun. Weil der Kaiser sich dadurch legitimiert oder das kaiserliche Haus legitimiert sich dadurch, die herrschende Klasse, dass sie die Muster des Himmels lesen kann. Aus den Mustern des Himmels, vor allen Dingen aus den Himmelsbewegungen kann man, also man hat daran geglaubt, dass es eine Verbindung zwischen den Mustern im Himmel und dem was auf der Erde passiert tatsächlich gibt. Das gibt natürlich den Astronomen am Hof eine unheimlich wichtige Stellung. Die beobachten den Himmel. Die sehen zum Beispiel einen Kometen, sie sehen sich den Lauf bestimmter Planeten an und entscheiden dann daraufhin, wie der Kaiser herrschen muss. Also ob es zum Beispiel ein Komet kann zum Beispiel ein gutes oder ein schlechtes Omen sein. Kann bedeuten, dass irgendwo eine gute Ernte stattfindet oder ein Erdbeben stattfindet oder dergleichen.
Also es gibt zum Beispiel eine Karte aus dem 9. Jahrhundert, wo man so eine Art Schachbrettmuster das asiatische Territorium geht und dieses Schachbrettmuster hat halt immer ein Äquivalent im Himmel. Das heißt wenn man in dem Quadranten im Himmel was beobachtet, dann wird auf dem Quadranten auf der Erde xyz passieren. Das heißt also insofern war auf jeden Fall Wissenschaft nicht unpolitisch. Es war vielleicht nicht gerade religiös, aber es definitiv nicht unpolitisch und es war sozial eben wirklich sehr relevant. Ein Kaiser, das passiert dann auch so zwischen dem 7. bis zum 11.-12. Jahrhundert, der den Kalender zum Beispiel nicht berechnen kann oder ein Kaiserhaus, der eben nicht die richtigen Experten anstellt, um die Jahreszeiten zu berechnen, wann die Sonnenwende kommt, wie lang die Tage sind, wann es zu einer Mondfinsternis zum Beispiel kommen wird.
Der war einfach nicht legitimiert zu herrschen. Das gibt der Astronomie natürlich einfach wirklich eine ziemliche politische Gewalt.
Das heißt in der Wahrnehmung der Gesellschaft war das eine Fähigkeit des Herrschers, der sich aber tatsächlich eigentlich aus der Fähigkeit der Astronomen, die für ihn gearbeitet haben, ableitet?
Absolut. Und deswegen waren zum Beispiel die Jesuiten damals auch sehr wichtig, weil die kamen von Europa. Die haben sich eigentlich nur einen Platz in China erkämpfen können, weil sie mit ihren Berechnungen nahe an der Realität lagen, also besser den Kalender berechnen konnten, besser eine Mondfinsternis vorhersagen konnten als die damaligen Ming-zeitlichen, also das ist die Dynastie, die damals herrschte, als die Ming-zeitlichen Astronomen. Die sich damals zum Beispiel noch auf eine persische Theorie beriefen. Auf eine etwa 300 Jahre alte Methode, die halt nicht mehr so ganz up to date war.
Aha also ganz ohne die Europäer ging es dann auch nicht?
Naja auf jeden Fall will die europäische Geschichte das gern so herstellen. Weil die Jesuiten eben tatsächlich auch diejenigen waren, die dann bestimmte Bereiche asiatischen Wissens, und das gilt auch für Indien zum Beispiel, also astronomische Berechnungen und dergleichen eben da gut mithalten konnten. Und das war ja auch ihre einzige Legitimation, um tatsächlich am Hof für den chinesischen Kaiser zum Beispiel wichtig zu sein. Wenn sie das nicht gekonnte hätten, wären sie wahrscheinlich niemals an den Hof gelassen worden. Genauso wie die damaligen persischen Astronomen auch. Also die Jesuiten waren da bestimmt nicht alleine auf weiter Flur. Und in Japan gibt es ein ähnliches Legitimationsschema zum Beispiel da war also auch astronomisches Wissen, die Kenntnisse des Himmels war eben ein Legitimitätsgrund für Herrschen und das gibt sozusagen dieser Wissenschaft einen ganz besonderen Rang.
Sind denn diese Leute auch als Wissenschaftler bezeichnet, also gab es überhaupt einen Begriff, so ein Selbstverständnis?
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Also es gibt tatsächlich ein Selbstverständnis für Astronomen. Also das sind diejenigen, die den Himmel lesen. Das hat immer auch etwas mit Astrologie zu tun oder mit Meteorologie. Es gibt grundsätzlich den Begriff der Gelehrten. Das bedeutet aber in chinesischen .. also zu bestimmten Zeiten bedeutet es natürlich unterschiedliche Sachen. Aber es bedeutet, dass man die kanonischen Werke kennt. Meistens auswendig von hinten bis vorne und dass man die Kommentarliteratur dazu kennt. Weil halt einfach Schrift lesen, schreiben und interpretieren, das war die wichtige Kenntnis, die man haben musste, um regieren zu können. Und dann gibt es eben ab diesem 10./11. Jahrhundert mit der Idee, dass Gelehrte an der Macht sein sollten, dass die also die Elite stellen sollten und nicht Aristokraten, also kein Geburtsrecht, gibt es eben eine Geschichtsschreibung, die das tatsächlich auch sehr stark hervorhebt und andere Trends halt auch unter sich begräbt.
Also da finden Sie, man kann sich vorstellen bei vielen Biografien, dass diese Personen vielleicht die Schrift nicht so gut gekannt haben, sondern eben wirklich exzellente Ingenieure waren oder Brückenbauer, aber die Dokumente geben das nicht mehr unbedingt im Detail her. Weil sie versuchen, die soziale Stellung herzustellen. Bisschen wie bei der Royal Academy in England, in der ja auch Gelehrte tatsächlich eine Stellung hatten, aber die aristokratische Stellung auch sehr stark betont wird, um zu zeigen, dass man dieser Person vertrauen kann, also dass diese Person jetzt auch ein respektabler Wissenschaftler ist war ja nicht nur einfach .. sagt man ja nicht einfach auf der Basis dessen, was die Person sagte, weil das glaubwürdig war, sondern weil diese Person eben eine wichtige soziale Stellung inne hatte.
Ohne Lord und ohne Duke vorne dran läuft da nichts.
Genau.
Und wann hat sich denn so dann eine moderne Weltsicht etabliert in China? Also wann hat man sozusagen so weit den Himmel lesen können, dass man festgestellt hat, dass vielleicht bisherige Annahmen überarbeitet gehören?
Das ist natürlich eine ideologische Frage. Sie hatten mich vorhin nach dieser Frage der Weltsicht gefragt. Also es gibt tatsächlich Christopher Cullen hat vor ein paar Jahren einen Artikel raus gelassen, der hat sich hauptsächlich mit Astronomiegeschichte beschäftigt, es gibt verschiedene Ideen vom Kosmos, wie der angelegt ist. Also im Wesentlichen gibt es zwei Theorien, man sagt immer, das eine muss man sich den Kosmos so vorstellen, wie ein Spiegelei. Also Sie haben in der Mitte sozusagen das Gelbe des Spiegeleis und außenrum haben Sie eine wabernde Masse und das andere Bild, das die Chinesen sich machen ist im Endeffekt eine quadratische Erde und darüber wie Schirm der Himmel. Das sind die zwei Bilder, mit denen sie sich den Kosmos oder die Erde vorstellen.
Also quadratisch im Sinne von flach quadratisch?
Flach quadratisch.
Also doch schon die Erde ist nicht eine Scheibe, sondern ein Quadrat.
Ja genau. Und auch mit diesem Eibild, also mit dem aufgeschlagenen Spiegelei, so ungefähr muss man sich das vorstellen, haben die Chinesen, die chinesischen Historiker bis vor ein paar Jahren eben tatsächlich gesagt, okay die Chinesen wussten schon, dieses Bild stammt ungefähr .. also man kann es zurückverfolgen auf 5. Jahrhundert vor Christus. Mit diesem Bild haben die Chinesen schon gewusst, dass die Erde rund ist. Aber ganz so einfach ist das nicht, wie Christopher Cullen das so schön in seinem Artikel gesagt hat, denn tatsächlich ist es ja ein Spiegelei. Also man stellt sich die Erde so irgendwie halbrund vor, aber das ganze Universum ist immer noch relativ flach.
Zweidimensional.
Genau. Und außenrum ist halt irgendwo das Universum eine wabernde Masse von Chi. Also das ganze Universum stellt man sich tatsächlich als einen Gegensatz Chi und Li. Das ist jetzt tatsächlich sehr intern. Also Chi ist so was wie Substanz, Materie, Energie, wie auch immer Sie das übersetzen wollen und es gibt sozusagen Prinzipien. Li einer Ration, die diese Substanzen oder Materie bestimmt. Und dann gibt es unterschiedliche, also unheimlich viele Intellektuelle, die einen glauben, nur Chi ist wichtig und die anderen glauben nur Li ist wichtig. Aber irgendwo in diesem Spannungsverhältnis wird die Welt erklärt. So ein bisschen auch, man kennt das ganz .. oder was so ein bisschen dann in der europäischen Rezeption so ankommt ist dieses Bild von Ying und Yang.
Also es gibt verschiedene Zustände von Chi, das eine ist weiblich, das andere ist männlich. Das eine ist hart, das andere ist weich. Und nur durch diese Komplementarität also tatsächlich kann die Welt bestehen. Also das ist ein relativ holistisches Weltbild eigentlich.
Oder man könnte sagen, die Welt besteht aus Chili. Das ist ja auch eine recht moderne Sicht.
Genau, ist auch eine recht moderne Sicht. Und diese Sicht ist tatsächlich sozusagen diese kosmischen Bildern, also diese Ideen von Kosmos, die sind halt immer wieder angezweifelt worden. Dann kamen halt die Inder und die haben ja ihre neun verschiedenen Himmel. Und dann die Perser bzw. das mechanistische Weltbild, das aus dem nahen Osten kommt, die sich da vermischen und die auch einen gewissen Einfluss aufeinander haben. Und es gibt da eben, weil es eben politisch wichtig ist, gibt es da viele Zäsuren drin. Also Sie finden da nicht einen Bruch. Und einen wesentlich Bruch, der relativ stark in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte betont ist, ist dann eben die Jesuiten, die gar nicht mal so sehr erklären, dass die Welt rund ist, als dass sie versuchen so eine Art tychonisches Weltbild in China zu etablieren, um den Kalender besser berechnen zu können.
Und das hat ein relativ großen Einfluss auf China, vor allen Dingen weil die damaligen Herrscher, die Manschuren, also die ja dann tatsächlich keine Chinesen mehr sind, eben auch einen echten Zwang hatten, sich zu legitimieren und sich eben nicht auf die traditionellen Ideen berufen, sondern darauf, dass sie mit Hilfe der Jesuiten das eben tatsächlich besser können. - Und die richtige Zesur kommt dann eigentlich erst im 18./19. Jahrhundert, als die Europäer nach und nach wirklich nach China eindringen und tatsächlich das damals auch relativ schwache China, die Qing-Dynastie eben anfangen zu zerstören. Also die politische Einheit tatsächlich zerstören. Mit den Opiumkriegen um 1850.
Dann tatsächlich auch de facto den Chinesen oder den damaligen Herrschern erklären, dass sie die Welt besser verstehen und sie kommen mit Dingen wie der Eisenbahn, wie den Dampfschiffen, das alles scheint sehr – oder dem haben die Chinesen tatsächlich nichts entgegenzusetzen in dieser Zeit. Und es kommt dann schnell so ein Narrativ auf, dass diese wissenschaftliche oder technische Entwicklung, die Dampfschiffe, die Eisenbahnen, die medizinische Entwicklung, die rüberkommt, dass man das braucht, um die Ausländer wieder rausschmeißen zu können. Und das ist so die große Zäsur, die man in der Geschichte auf jeden Fall in Richtung auf wissenschaftliches und technisches Denken sieht.
Das heißt das war dann sozusagen die Geburtsstunde der chinesischen industriellen Revolution, dass man gesehen hat, wie weit die Engländer voran sind und dass man sie aber eigentlich nicht hier haben möchte und um sie jetzt rauszukicken braucht man halt auch Dampfrösser.
Ja da kommt auf jeden Fall die Geschichte auf, dass das so ist. Aber gerade wenn Sie industrielle Revolution ansprechen, wenn Sie zum Beispiel die Porzellanmanufaktor im 13./14./15. Jahrhundert anschauen, 16./17. Jahrhundert. Denken Sie nur an die Chinoiserien, die man heute in Europa sieht. Porzellan ist eines der Dinge, die in China industriell seit mehr als 1000 Jahren hergestellt wurden. Also wirklich bis soweit, dass ganze Regionen Chinesen nicht dahingehen wollten. Jingdezhen, weil das halt einfach voll mit, also ich glaube da gibt es eine Stelle in der Geschichte Jingdezhen ist voll mit Schornsteinen. Das ist absolut hässliche Umgebung, weil ja überall der Lehm abgebaut wurde, um diese Porzellanherstellung zu betreiben. Dann die ganze Region war völlig entwaldet, also das war wohl Industrialisierung im schlimmsten Sinne.
Also genauso wie die Schiffsherstellung in Fujian, die auch schon im 14./15. Jahrhundert wirklich industrialisiert war. Das ist die gleiche Region, wo der Buchdruck damals kommerzialisiert wurde, wo man Dokumente hat, die im Endeffekt davon sprechen, dass die ganze Region entwaldet war, weil soviel für diese beiden Industrien Papierherstellung, Buchdruckherstellung und Schiffsbau.
Was alles Holz brauchte.
Was alles Holz brauchte ja. Da sehen Sie sozusagen, ja Industrialisierung im europäischen Sinne war vorher schon da, aber kommt dann im 19. Jahrhundert dann eben mit Maschinen. Und mit einer anderen Vorstellung davon, was Industrialisierung ist. Aber es ist bestimmt nicht neu, dass es so eine Art Massenproduktion gibt. Die gab es vorher auch schon.
Das heißt diese Schwächung der chinesischen wissenschaftlichen Entwicklung kam halt dann immer wieder mit irgendwelchen schwächelnden Dynastien daher, obwohl schon so große Fortschritte gemacht wurden vorher. Man ja einfach davon ausgehen kann, Schwarzpulver etc., das sind ja immer so ein bisschen die Klassiker, die man gerne erwähnt und sieht. Dass das ja dann eigentlich auch schnell zu einem Fundament, zu einem technischen Fundament führen sollte, auf dem sich diese Entwicklung mehr oder weniger verselbstständigt.
Ja aber ich meine, das können Sie natürlich von der europäischen Kultur noch auch so nicht sagen. Also was die chinesischen Wissenschaftshistoriker oft anführen und was ich gar nicht so unklug finde, wenn Sie sich die europäische Entwicklung auf der Basis der modernen Naturwissenschaften oder der modernen Technik anschauen, dann spricht man heute von einer Periode, die ungefähr um 18 vielleicht Ende des 19. Jahrhundert oder dergleichen ansetzt, wo das dann tatsächlich wirklich stark nach vorne getrieben wird. Das sind knapp 100 Jahre. Also die hat China schon mal öfter gehabt, wo sie weit sozusagen der europäischen Kultur technisch und wissenschaftlich voraus waren. Das sind bestimmte Perioden. Und wenn wir auf eine andere Region zu sprechen kommen wollen. Das finden Sie im sudanesischen Reich zum Beispiel. Das finden Sie im nigerianischen Reich. Wo zum Beispiel die Metalogie im 7./8./9. Jahrhundert wesentlich weiter entwickelt war in Europa.
Und Sie finden das eben im indischen Bereich auch, dass es immer wieder Perioden gibt, wo eben tatsächlich wissenschaftliches und technisches Denken wesentlich weiter entwickelt ist und dann plötzlich zu einem Stillstand kommt. Das kann soziale Ursachen haben, das kann politische Ursachen haben. Und wie gesagt, Europa ist nicht so lange vorne dran, dass man nicht sagen könnte, das ist vielleicht auch nur ein temporales Phänomen.
Ja ich wollte jetzt auch nicht Europa hochjubeln. Aber ich frage mich halt nur immer ein wenig, wie jetzt wirklich, also welche Bedeutung konkret die Wissenschaft für die vor allem chinesische Gesellschaft oder überhaupt für den asiatischen Raum hatte. Und was mich auch nochmal interessieren würde, ob es denn überhaupt irgendwo so einen Zeitpunkt gab, wo man eben so einen Begriff gebildet hat dafür. Also diese Idee, Wissenschaftler zu sein, einen Beruf zu haben, der eben jetzt nicht unmittelbare Dinge tut oder dass man Schreiner ist der eben Reisbauer oder was auch immer. Sondern dass man sich sozusagen der Forschung, dem Anstreben neuer Erkenntnisse hinwendet und dann eben vielleicht auch entsprechende Institutionen begründet, wie Universitäten, wie Akademien in irgendeiner Form. Gab es das überhaupt und wann, wenn hat es denn eingesetzt?
Auch das finden Sie tatsächlich, es scheint repetitiv, aber man findet das tatsächlich auch ab dem 5. Jahrhundert vor Christus. Herrscher haben Akademien und Schulen eingeführt. Dann die dynastischen Herrscher ab der Han-Dynastie haben Bibliotheken etabliert. Zuerst am Hof, dann gibt es bestimmte Perioden in der Tang-Dynastie, wo es monastische Schulen gibt und man findet so einen richtigen Schub nach vorne, auch hier eigentlich muss man sagen, also zwischen dem 10./12./13. Jahrhundert und dann nochmal ab dem 14./15. Jahrhundert, wo dann tatsächlich der Staat systematisch in allen Kreisen überall öffentliche Schulen eingerichtet hat. Sie hatten einen großen Bedarf an Beamten. Also die Idee war tatsächlich, dass man zuerst einmal lernt, zu denken. Und wenn man gelernt hat zu denken, auf der Basis also wirklich theoretischen Wissens, ohne zu forschen zu verstehen, philologisch zu denken, Dinge zu durchdenken, dann ist man in der Lage mit weltlichen Dingen umzugehen.
Und so hat man dann die Beamten rekrutiert. Und weil das eine Möglichkeit war, gesellschaftlich vorwärts zu kommen, haben unheimlich viele Leute, man spricht heute davon, dass mindestens – also es gibt verschiedene Schätzungen, wild Idee, man hat einmal gesagt, das sind vielleicht irgendwie 80% der Leute konnten schreiben und lesen und meinte damit, sie konnten definitiv ihren Namen schreiben und lesen, aber eben vielleicht von 5-20% der Bevölkerung in diesen Perioden konnte die Klassiker lesen würde man sagen. Und wie gesagt es gibt unterschiedliche Schätzungen davon. Die bewegen sich in diesen Zahlen. Aber wenn man sich schon alleine die Millionen vorstellt, dann sind das Massen, dann sind das relativ viele Massen, die sich damit beschäftigen, nicht Reis anzubauen, keinen Schiffsbau zu betreiben, keine Schreinerei zu machen, sondern Bücher zu lesen und zu forschen, die Welt zu verstehen, sich mit Linguistik zu beschäftigen.
Also Dinge, die keinen, wenn man es so sagen möchte, kein direkten Nutzen haben.
Nochmal die Zeitmarke dafür?
Die Zeitmarke finden Sie tatsächlich ab dem 9. Jahrhundert würde ich sagen. Und diese hohen Zahlen spricht man heute so ab dem 14./15. Jahrhundert geht man davon aus, dass ein Großteil der chinesischen Bevölkerung lesen und schreiben kann. Denken Sie nur an Marco Polo. Der ja bei den Mongolen war bei Kublai Khan, der gesagt hat, hier können alle Leute lesen und schreiben. Das war vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber tatsächlich in den Städten konnten tatsächlich viele Leute lesen und schreiben. Mussten sie auch, es gab viele Händler, es gab eben aber einfach eine echte Ausbildung in öffentlichen Schulen. Natürlich haben trotzdem diejenigen, die es sich leisten konnten versucht, ihre Kinder noch besser zu Hause zu erziehen. Aber es gab Akademien, die finden Sie allerdings schon auch im 2. Jahrhundert vor Christus. Also wer es sich leisten konnte hat auch damals schon seinen Nachwuchs auf Akademien geschickt. Wo man genau diese Dinge lernte.
14./15. Jahrhundert.
Genau.
Das ist die Ming-Dynastie, die mit der Vase.
Genau, das sind die mit den Vasen. Mit den blau-weißen. Die ja auch wieder davon spricht, dass eben ganz vieles von dem eben wirklich nicht tatsächlich chinesisch ist, aber chinesisch rezipiert wurde, weil das blau-weiß kommt zum Beispiel aus dem persischen Raum. Das ist gar nichts chinesisches eigentlich. Die Materialien, die Idee, die Technik, das kommt alles ja aus diesem zentralasiatischen Raum, wo wir heute wissen, dass viele diese Erfindung oder Kreationen einfach ihren Ursprung haben. Weil sich dort viele Völker vermischt haben. Viele Ideen ausgetauscht haben.
Gab es dann auch einen Namen für Wissenschaftler?
Nein. Also die ganz klare Antwort ist, nein. Die gab es nicht. Es gab den Namen eines Gelehrten. Und es gab einen Schüler und einen Lehrer. Aber es gab keinen Namen für den Wissenschaftler. Es gab auch keinen Namen für den Techniker. Es gibt einen Begriff, den man mit so was wie Kunst oder Kunstfertigkeit in Verbindung bringt, aber der hat auch oft einen negativen Anklang, im Sinn dass jemand, der Künstler oder Kunst ist, nicht immer unbedingt derjenige ist, der es mit der Wahrheit so genau nimmt. Also man könnte vielleicht sagen, so was wie ein Trickster. Oder jemand der sich mit Astrologie und Vorhersagen beschäftigt, Devination. Das kann einen positiven Anklang haben, kann aber auch negativen Anklang haben.
Aber der Wissenschaftler an sich war auch nicht wirklich viel wert. Weil der die tatsächliche – dass man Brücken bauen konnte war ja nur dann relevant, wenn man wusste, warum man die Brücke baut und welchen sozialen Effekt sie zum Beispiel hat oder welchen politischen Effekt sie hat. Das heißt das Wissen an sich ist einfach ganz anders bewertet worden. Wie moralisch ist das. Welchen gesellschaftlichen Nutzen hat es tatsächlich. Das findet man ganz oft in diesen Dokumenten. Also das reine Wissen, um zu wissen, hat nicht immer unbedingt einen guten Anklang gehabt in Asien. Und zwar im Sinne von, jedes und da kommt vielleicht auch dieser Begriff der Abteilung, also jedes Wissen, es gibt kein aktionsloses Wissen. Kein handlungsunspezifisches Wissen.
Jedes Wissen ist tatsächlich mit irgendeiner Handlung verbunden und das bedeutet, man muss sich über die moralischen Konsequenzen Gedanken machen. Da gibt es dann eben so ab dem 15./16. Jahrhundert einen sehr intensiven Diskurs drüber. Aber eben auch ich denke auch im gewissen Sinne so eine Überzeugung, dass sich Moral, Wissen und Handlen nicht voneinander trennen lassen.
Ist das so viel anders als es die Europäer sehen zum Beispiel?
Wenn Sie mich ganz ehrlich fragen, ich glaube nein. Aber ich glaube, dass die Wissenschaftsgeschichte in der europäischen Tradition sehr stark darauf geachtet hat, sich selber als objektiv, neutral, abstrakt darzustellen. Das Dinge wie Moral auch im sozusagen in dieser Entwicklung aus der besonderen europäischen Tradition der Frage der Religiösität, der Verbindung zu Machtdenken und dergleichen, sich eben sehr stark versucht hat, da herauszubewegen, und dafür zu argumentieren, dass es ein rationales Wissen gibt, was bar einer moralischen Komponente sein kann. Eine Art neutrales Wissen. Und das ist tatsächlich etwas, ich will nicht sagen, das wurde auch in China und ich denke vor allen Dingen auch in wahrscheinlich auch in anderen Regionen, stark diskutiert.
Aber es gibt keinen so starken Trend, dieses unbedingt trennen zu wollen. Oder darauf zu basieren, dass das sozusagen eine Voraussetzung für die Entwicklung naturwissenschaftlichen Wissens ist, was man ja heute auch sagen würde. Es gibt eigentlich kein Wissen, das nicht irgendeine moralische Komponente, einen Effekt hat, den man nicht beachten müsste.
Aber der Unterschied war dann wahrscheinlich, dass es natürlich jetzt auch es dann in Asien nicht so stark wie in Europa so eine Bedrohung eigentlich für die Forschung und die Wissenschaft ausging. Ich meine diese Auseinandersetzungen zwischen der Kirche und den Wissenschaftlern Galilei etc., die jeden Tag immer Angst hatten, dass ihr Weltbild umkippt und damit irgendwie ihr Zugriff auf die Gesellschaft, auf dem das alles basiert, scheint ja so in der Form in China zum Beispiel kein Äquivalent zu haben.
Absolut, es hat kein Äquivalent. Es ist auch eigentlich irrelevant. Also es ist tatsächlich das einzige, was wirklich, was vielleicht vergleichbar ist, ist die Frage, ob man den Kalender genau berechnen kann und ob man die Mond- und Sonnenfinsternisse tatsächlich vernünftig vorhersagen kann. Wobei sich natürlich auch die Idee der Präzession da ändert. Also es ist irgendwann mal völlig in Ordnung, wenn man das mit einer halben Stunde Diskrepanz vorhersagen kann und irgendwann im 14./15./16. Jahrhundert ist das tatsächlich nicht mehr in Ordnung. Also empfinden das die Herrscher tatsächlich schon als einen Misserfolg. Aber es gibt nicht diesen Versuch, dass zu einem Clash von Weltbildern zu machen. Das passiert tatsächlich einfach nicht.
Wann kann man denn sagen ist denn China so in der Moderne angekommen? Also dieser Widerstand gegen die europäischen Invasoren scheint mehr so ein bisschen ein Aufbruch gewesen zu sein. Jetzt habe ich im Prinzip zwei Fragen noch im Kopf. Also erstens oder gehen wir einfach mal gleich auf die Ist-Situation, wenn man jetzt sagen wir mal das Selbstverständnis wissenschaftlicher Entwicklung in Asien nimmt, wie sich auch der einzelne in dieser Tradition sieht und das jetzt mit einem Europäer vergleichen würde, was ist da anders? Ist das schon alles überlagert von unserer Globalmoderne und ist das jetzt wirklich ein Thing of the Past, oder lässt sich da noch irgendwie ein Unterschied ablesen in der Herangehensweise, in der Methodik vielleicht auch oder auch eben wie man sich da selbst als Teil der Gesellschaft sieht?
Also dieser ganze Diskurs von der Wissenschaftsgeschichte und der Wissenschaftsgeschichte oder der Wissenschaft als europäisches Phänomen hat in ganz Asien würde ich sagen, und ich würde da sowohl China als auch Indien als auch Südostasien mit einbeziehen, einen völlig anderen Stellenwert, weil halt die eigene Modernität dadurch in Frage gestellt wird oder nicht. Das heißt in diesen Regionen besteht das Gefühl, dass sozusagen die Naturwissenschaften ihren Ursprung in Europa haben. Und dass man deswegen in Asien sehr lange hinterher gehinkt ist. Das macht natürlich die wissenschaftliche oder technische Entwicklung heute eben auch sehr relevant dazu, wie man seinen eigenen Entwicklungsstand sieht. Das heißt es wird als eine Frage der nationalen Identität gesehen, dass man a) auf jeden Fall in China, das ist in Indien und Südostasien aufgrund der anderen Geschichtsschreibung einfach nicht so leicht zu legitimieren, dass man auch wesentlich an wissenschaftlichen und technischen Entwicklungen mitgewirkt hat, wenn nicht sogar sie bestimmt hat.
Das ist sozusagen eine Frage des eigenen Nationalstolzes. Wie man bei dieser Olympiade in 2008 gesehen hat, wo diese vier Erfindungen ja ganz hochgehoben wurden in dem Feuerwerk. Aber auch in Indien und dergleichen ist halt Wissenschaft und Technik einfach zur Definition des neuen, des modernen, des fortschrittlichen Staates geworden, über diese ganze Diskussion des 20. Jahrhunderts, Kapitalismus, Kommunismus etc. Hinweg. Auch über diese politischen Diskrepanzen hinweg, ist Wissenschaft und Technik einfach das Emblem der Modernität. Und das muss tatsächlich dann einfach vorangetrieben werden. Und diese Wissenschaft und Technik ist ziemlich ahistorisch. Das heißt sie ist modern, sie besteht hauptsächlich aus den Naturwissenschaften, sie besteht aus der Idee, dass ist in Japan in Korea und China so, selbst in Regionen, die sagen wir mal entwicklungstechnisch wesentlich weiter weg sind, wie der Mongolei.
Dass man nicht nur versucht, industriell hinterher zu kommen, sondern eben einfach auch naturwissenschaftlich und so was ähnliches wie Basisforschung, Grundlagenforschung vorantreibt, weil das ein Emblem sehr lange ein Emblem des Westens war in seiner Fortschrittlichkeit.
Die ganzen großen grundsätzlichen Entscheidungen und Entdeckungen gemacht zu haben.
Genau. Das ist genau das, Physik, Chemie, Mathematik, es gibt in China, das ist glaube ich so eines der Embleme, die auch ab und zu mal in der Presse vorkommen, die Idee, dass die gesamte Bevölkerung an die Naturwissenschaften herangetrieben werden muss, deswegen hat man 2002 Millionen bereitgestellt und in jeder etwas größeren Stadt ein Naturwissenschaftsmuseum, eine sogenannte Ausstellungshalle zu gründen, damit eben jeder dorthin gehen kann und die modernen Wissenschaften bewundern kann. Und diese modernen Wissenschaften haben keine historische Verankerung, sie sind neu, sie sind europäisch, sie sind vielleicht global, aber sie sind nicht verbunden mit dem, was 2,500 Jahre vorher passiert ist.
Ist das zu bedauern oder ist das einfach so?
Ich glaube, die Museumsbetreiber bedauern das, weil die Chinesen selber gehen nicht sehr gerne in diese Museen. Sie finden sie tatsächlich sehr langweilig. Weil ihnen einfach der Bezug dazu fehlt. Für die Naturwissenschaft, also für die …
Also weil gerade dieser historische Bezug nicht hergestellt wird?
Ja, weil es gibt keine, für das Individuum gibt es keine Möglichkeit, sich damit in Verbindung zu bringen.
Zu identifizieren.
Ja, es ist so global, dass es mit dem eigenen Leben einfach nichts mehr zu tun hat. Es ist abstrakt und man hat keine emotionale Bindung dazu. Und das macht tatsächlich sehr viel aus.
Heißt das, es gibt keine Newtons und keine Galileis in China?
Es ist ganz lustig, weil tatsächlich verbringe ich oder bestreite ich meinen Lebensunterhalt damit, mir diese Personen genau anzuschauen, die eben eigentlich Newtons und Galileos sind. Aber nie zu diesem Ruhm gelangt sind. Also die ähnliche durchbrechende Erkenntnisse hatten, ob das jetzt in der Evolutionsbiologie war oder in der Physik oder in der Astronomie. Aber die Chinesen selber haben ein relativ ambivalentes Verhältnis dazu. Das heißt sie finden im Museum der Geschichte finden Sie solche Personen. Das heißt Sie finden einen, also Galileo ist zum Beispiel Shen Gua. Das ist ein Astronom, eigentlich ist es ein Polymat. Also jemand, der zum Beispiel auch ein Gefäß erfunden hat, mit dem man Erdbeben vorsehen, einen Seismographen erfunden hat, mit dem man Erdbeben voraussagen konnte. Auf jeden Fall relativ gut sagen konnte, wie lange es dauert, bis die Wellen von einem Erdbeben, das zum Beispiel in Tibet stattfand, in Sichuan angekommen sind.
Also ein wirklich sehr intelligenter Mensch, den man hier in Europa wahrscheinlich gar nicht kennt. Diese Person findet man in China dargestellt in einem Geschichtsmuseum. Wenn Sie aber zum Beispiel in dem modernen, in Shanghai gibt es ein ganz großes Naturwissenschaftsmuseum, gehen, dann finden Sie diese Person nicht, Sie finden aber Einstein und Galileo und den Hinweis darauf, dass Einstein Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts in Shanghai war, also es ist ein sehr schwieriges Verhältnis, das hier zu Naturwissenschaft und zur Technik eben einfach auch offengelegt wird.
Ist ja interessant. Warum ist das so? Also gehen die Chinesen einfach mit so einem Personenkult anders um an der Stelle oder wollen sie es nicht daran festmachen oder sind jetzt wirklich auch nur die Leistungen nicht ausreichend oder werden zumindest nicht als ausreichend betrachtet? Was ist der Grund dafür?
Der Grund ist, Sie fragen einen Historiker, der Grund ist tatsächlich die Geschichte des 20. Jahrhunderts. Der Kolonialismus, der Postkolonialismus, die Dominanz, die aus dem Westen kam, die Idee, dass die Wissenschaften aus dem Westen kamen und man muss sich nur vorstellen, dass die Idee, dass es außerhalb von Europa eine wissenschaftliche und technische Entwicklung gegeben hat, mit besonderer Bezugnahme zum Beispiel auf China, von einem Briten stand. Von Joseph Needham. Es kommt ja noch nicht einmal sozusagen von den Chinesen selber, die sich hingestellt haben und gesagt haben, wir hatten aber auch Personen wie Shengua oder Hoang-Sung-Shi oder Wuang-Fut, die ganz tolle mathematische Ideen hatten. Die ein neues Weltbild entworfen haben. Die den Seismografen, wie ich gerade gesagt habe, entwickelt haben. Das kam nicht von den Chinesen selber, sondern das kam von Joseph Needham.
Und es war Joseph Needham, ein Brite, ein Diplomchemiker, der sich mit Evolutionstheorien beschäftigt, der in den 30er Jahren als Diplomat nach Sitschuang gegangen ist, um die britische Regierung dort zu vertreten, der zu einem Kollegen, Robert Merton und dergleichen, erzählt hat, da gibt es aber viele Sachen, da dachten wir, die sind europäisch, das haben die Chinesen aber schon viel früher gewusst. Und das haben die Japaner viel früher gewusst. Er hat versucht, es selber auch mit Indien zu machen, nur leider war die politische Situation in Indien so, dass er es nie geschafft hat, oder dass es nie zu einem Geschichtswerk gekommen ist, der sich das so systematisch angeguckt hat, was hat die Kultur wissenschaftlich und technisch eigentlich hervorgebracht. Und das ist auch heute noch so, dass Sie durch die Straßen von China gehen, ich schwöre Ihnen, Sie sagen, den chinesischen Namen von Joseph Needham und jedes Kind in China kennt Joseph Needham.
Wie heißt denn das auf Chinesisch dann?
Li Yuese
Die Verbindung ist schwer zu schlagen
Sie können es auch hinschreiben, also die Chinesen kennen den einfach. Er hat ihnen ihre Ehre wiedergegeben, er hat in einer Periode, in der China wirklich am Boden lag, und tatsächlich in diesen Selbstbehauptungsdiskursen, die damals stattgefunden haben, also wo die Chinesen versucht haben, ihr eigenes Land, es gab eine Periode, in der China halt eben von den 1860/70er Jahren, aber tatsächlich ab 1912 sehr innerlich zerrissen war. Es gab keine Regierung, die über das gesamte Territorium herrschte und in der Periode kommt ein Brite und gibt ihnen ihren Nationalstolz wieder. Und erklärt ihnen, ihr habt aber doch so viel geleistet. Und das ist tatsächlich, das macht zum Beispiel wahrscheinlich auch China in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte zu diesen anderen, im Vergleich zu Europa, weil damit einfach tatsächlich ein anderes Bild von Anfang an geschaffen wurde.
Das selbe ist nie geleistet worden für Indien, es ist nie geleistet worden für Arabien, es ist nie geleistet worden für den afrikanischen Kontinent oder für Südamerika. Da gibt es einfach die Vorarbeiten nicht.
Ist jetzt auch sehr interessant zu sehen, dass so im Rahmen dieser Aufholbewegung gerade ja China und Indien auch extrem ins All drängen und hier sich in der Raumfahrt betätigen. Im Falle von Indien sehr wohl auch in weitgehender Kooperation mit dem Rest der Welt. China scheint sehr auf so einem, zumindest noch, auf so einem Einzelweg zu bestehen. Schwer zu sagen, ob sie teilweise einfach nicht mitspielen dürfen oder nicht mitspielen wollen. Was könnte es sein? Was ist wahrscheinlicher?
Also die Chinesen haben ja unter anderem auch die Raketen erfunden. Das ist einer der Dinge, die es tatsächlich bis ins Naturwissenschaftsmuseum gemacht hat. Die Raumfahrtstechnologien war immer extrem wichtig, insbesondere für die Volksrepublik China. Sogar über die Kulturrevolution hinaus. Also während dieser Periode, als fast alle anderen Naturwissenschaften oder viele von diesen Bereichen mehr oder minder eingefroren wurden. Diese Forschung macht gerade ein Kollege von mir Fanfati aus Binghampton, wurde zum Beispiel die Raumfahrt weitergeführt. Das andere, was ich ganz spannend finde, die Raumfahrt und die Paläoarchäologie, die wurde zum Beispiel auch weitergeführt. Also China-Man, der erste der Peking-Mann das sind so zwei der Bereiche, die tatsächlich über diese ganzen politischen Spannungen und die Schwierigkeiten in dieser Periode immer einen wichtigen politischen Anspruch geltend gemacht haben.
Und das ist für die Chinesen tatsächlich immer noch sehr wichtig. Ich denke aber, soweit ich das als Historikerin beurteilen kann, es ist nicht unbedingt etwas, was man nach außen trägt. Aber Sie sehen ja zum Beispiel die Chinesen haben sehr stark in die Teilchenforschung investiert und sie machen das ja teilweise auch sehr schnell und unbeobachtet von der Öffentlichkeit. Also vor ungefähr zwei Jahren, die Max-Planck-Gesellschaft ist da übrigens auch dran beteiligt, hat ein Physiker, ein chinesischer Physiker, der auch sehr lange in CERN gearbeitet hat, tatsächlich herausgefunden, mehr oder minder überraschend, dass beim Bau der Bahn von China nach Tibet, die gibt es ja jetzt seit einiger Zeit können Sie da rüberfahren. Dass es einen Berg gab, der eine besondere Gesteinszusammensetzung hat, der es optimal für solche Forschungen macht, weil halt eben diese Teilchen nur durchkommen.
Es ist glaube ich hauptsächlich Marmor. Ich habe die tatsächliche Zusammensetzung vergessen. Und dann wurde innerhalb von einem Jahr beschlossen, dass man unter diesem Berg, unter den sowieso ein Tunnel geführt wurde, eben zusätzlich noch ein Labor baut, um diese Teilchenforschung ..
Also so einen Beschleunigungsring baut?
So einen Beschleunigungsring baut, genau. Und das sind Entwicklungen, die werden glaube ich von der Öffentlichkeit nicht wahrgenommen. Auf jeden Fall besteht da seit zwei Jahren exzellente Laborbedingungen. Es wird wirklich ganz vorne Grundlagenforschung gemacht. Natürlich, man muss bedenken, dass in den 70er Jahren des 20. Jahrhunderts China noch ganz woanders stand, aber wenn man sieht, wo es jetzt steht und welche Art von Forschung es macht, dann kann einem schon schwindlig werden. Also ich glaube, da passiert tatsächlich viel mehr als hier wahrgenommen wird. Weil einfach die Presse, das sind einfach zu viele Nachrichten, um sie tatsächlich zu verarbeiten. Und es ist auch nicht unbedingt das, was zieht.
Ich meine, in der europäischen und vielleicht auch besonders in der deutschen Sicht nimmt man ja glaube ich China und Japan sehr als kopierfreudige Nation wahr. Ich will das jetzt gar nicht mal als was schlechtes darstellen. Aber auf der einen Seite gibt es immer so ein bisschen die Befürchtung, oh Gott wenn ich jetzt eine Depardence in China habe und so weiter, die gucken sich dann sozusagen drei Jahre unsere Technologie an und dann bauen sie es selber. Auch Japan ist ja im Prinzip in den 80er Jahren vor allem auch sehr stark aufgetreten, weil sie halt einfach das selbe getan haben wie die anderen, bloß eben es einfach effizienter, schneller, billiger hinbekamen, dadurch groß geworden sind, insbesondere mit ihren Elektronikunternehmen. Und man fragt sich natürlich dann immer schon so ein bisschen, okay was ist denn jetzt das eigentliche, was ihr mitbringt?
Angenommen China würde, man stelle sich vor, man würde jetzt in Grundlagenforschung, vielleicht auch im industriellen Bereich, vollständig zu Europa aufschließen. Ist schwer zu bewerten, aber nur mal so rein theoretisch, gibt es dann das Potenzial dieser Kultur dann auch wirklich voranzuschreiten? Oder müssten sie sich erst mal wieder hinstellen und warten?
Also Sie sagten vorhin, drei Jahre, ich glaube, also Imitation, wenn sie in Asien drei Monate dauert, dann ist das schon sehr pessimistisch geschätzt, im Sinne von es dauert nicht so lange. Und zwar weil einfach die Masse und das Interesse an solchen Imitationen und der Weiterentwicklung solcher Imitationen wirklich schnell ist. Ich versuche nicht, hier ein positives Bild zu zeichnen, aber wenn man tatsächlich in Asien sich bewegt und ich schließe hier zum Beispiel auch Indien ein. Wenn Sie zum Beispiel über die IT-Entwicklung dort nachdenken. Es gibt einfach eine sehr viel positivere Haltung gegenüber solchen technischen und wissenschaftlichen Entwicklungen. Genetische Forschungen zum Beispiel. Embryonalforschung. Es gibt Bereiche, die werden dort eben extrem stark vorangetrieben, die in Europa zurecht vielleicht mit sehr viel Misstrauen betrachtet werden.
Und ich glaube, man kann heute zurecht sagen, dass es Bereiche gibt, in denen, zum Beispiel Astrophysik ist China weiter als die meisten anderen Nationen, es wird halt tatsächlich einfach nicht wahrgenommen. Aber das heißt nicht, dass es nicht stattfindet. Evolutionsbiologie, genetische Manipulation von Getreidesorten. Ganz klar sind die meisten Laboratorien, die sich mit solchen Fragen beschäftigen in Asien angesiedelt. Nicht mal unbedingt in China, aber definitiv in Asien. Und da sollte man sich nicht vormachen, dass die Hauptentwicklungen tatsächlich heute in Europa stattfinden. Das ist vielleicht schon zu optimistisch gedacht.
Könnte es sein, dass wir uns auch so ein bisschen in so einer Sättigungsphase befinden? Also wenn ich so ein bisschen zurückdenke, auch noch Nachkriegszeit, als die Nutzung der Kohle eigentlich überhaupt erst so richtig einsetzte, und sehr schnell technologische Fortschritte aufeinander folgten, die allesamt erhebliche Auswirkungen hatten auf die Ernährung, wie man wohnt, wie man Arbeit abgenommen bekommt. Sei es nur eine Waschmaschine oder ein Kühlschrank. Also all diese grundlegenden Sachen, die für uns jetzt vollkommen selbstverständlich sind, weil sie einfach da sind. Die aber im Prinzip die Lebensverhältnisse in Europa innerhalb von 50-60 Jahren so radikal umgeschaufelt haben, dass es da auch noch so eine Begeisterung gab. Das ist ja Fortschritt, das Wort an sich fing ja schon an zu strahlen, weil das sozusagen immer der Blick auf die noch schönere Zukunft war.
Und da gab es ja dann auch noch das Jahr 2000, das war ja überhaupt das tollste so. Und jetzt ist 2000 so ein bisschen durch. Man hat so das Gefühl, naja lebt sich ja jetzt eigentlich ganz gut. Und so diese Verheißung von Wissenschaft und Forschung, im Sinne von der Verbesserung der Lebensumstände ist so ein bisschen in die zweite Reihe geraten. Während das natürlich in China und insbesondere auch nochmal in Indien eine ganz andere Geschichte ist, weil eben einfach die Zivilisation, wie wir sie als Mitteleuropäer vor allem wahrnehmen, so einfach gar nicht existent ist. Und dass deswegen so eine Grund – das ist jetzt so ein bisschen der Versuch einer Schlussfolgerung und auch dieses mit dem Imitieren sehr positiv zu sehen, weil selbstverständlich, wenn man quasi Nachholungsbedarf hat, dann ist man ja offen, dann ist man aufgeschlossen und dann lernt man schnell wie ein Kind und imitiert halt. Weil das einfach nun mal der schnellstmögliche Weg ist, Fortschritt zu beschreiten.
Ja absolut, würde ich auch so sehen. Zumal ja die Idee, was eigentlich wichtig ist, um eine Kultur weiterzubringen, und wo sich eine Kultur jetzt befindet, eben der wichtige Antriebsmotor ist, um sich tatsächlich weiter zu entwickeln. Und Sie haben zum Beispiel bei China, Japan, Indien ein unheimlichen Druck, die ganzen Schweirigkeiten auch aus dem Weg zu räumen. Ob das jetzt die Umweltverschmutzung ist, die durch die Industrialisierung gekommen ist, die einfach es notwendig macht, Solarenergie oder Wind- und Wasserkraft anders zu nutzen, als man das bisher gedacht hat. Denken Sie an die Solarindustrie, die ja inzwischen ja sehr stark asienbetont ist. Der Druck ist tatsächlich mehr da und der führt dazu, dass man eben nicht nur bereitwillig imitiert, sondern auch eben sehr schnell sehr kreativ wird.
Elektroautos sind zum Beispiel in Asien ein unheimlicher Renner, aber hier sehr schwer auf den Markt zu bringen. Also da denke ich, dieses die Nachfrage der ökonomische, der ökologische Druck, der soziale Druck, sich weiterzuentwickeln ist denke ich, und da spreche ich sozusagen eher aus persönlicher Perspektive als als Historiker, ist wahrscheinlich momentan in Asien sehr viel größer als er in Europa ist.
Ich glaube man macht sich diese Beschleunigung hier auch nicht so richtig klar. Es gibt immer diese schönen Bilder von Shanghai vor 20 Jahren und Shanghai heute. Oder man muss sich auch nur mal allein was sich in den letzten zehn Jahren getan hat in Bezug auf U-Bahnnetze. Also Millionenmetropolen, die nicht eine einzige Linie hatten, haben so binnen 10-15 Jahren Netze, die jegliche Komplexität des Londoner oder Pariser Metrosystems in den Schatten stellen und ich glaube, das ist etwas, was hier so einfach noch gar nicht angekommen ist. Was kann man denn mitnehmen aus diesen Lehren der chinesischen Wissenschaftskultur, wenn man das überhaupt so nennen kann oder der Art und Weise mit Lernen und Forschen umzugehen? Was sind denn da so Lektionen, die man vielleicht mal nehmen sollte? Was uns entweder abhanden gekommen ist oder sich so hier noch nie so Raum geboten hat? Was bietet sich denn da an?
Ich glaube, dass man sich ernsthaft mit Alternativen beschäftigen muss. Also wenn unser Bild von wie wissenschaftliche und technische Entwicklung ablaufen soll, von der Idee, dass Kreativität, Liberalität Raum braucht, Demokratie braucht etc. Was mitunter Umständen auch tatsächlich so sein mag, sich die andere Seite anzuschauen. Zum Beispiel wie viel Planung verträgt Wissenschaft? Was bedeutet es überhaupt sozusagen, zielorientiert Wissenschaft zu betreiben? Also relativ pragmatische Wissenschaften im Vergleich zu so was wie ein Open-Ended-Enterprise oder dergleichen. Das sind alles Dinge, die Sie in solchen Kulturen finden und mit denn ja auch periodisch wissenschaftliches und technisches Denken immer mal wieder sehr große Fortschritte gemacht hat.
Das heißt die Fragen einfach so, was sind die Paradigmen, die Wissenschaft und technische Entwicklung außerhalb von Europa tatsächlich weitergeführt haben, tatsächlich ernst zu nehmen und sie sich aus einer historischen Perspektive anzuschauen. Das ist eines so der Dinge, die man nicht nur in der modernen ökonomischen Entwicklung in Asien jetzt sehen kann, sondern in der historischen Entwicklung über einen weiten globalen Raum sich eben auch anschauen muss. Was sind andere historische Alternative gewesen, die wissenschaftliches und technisches Denken gefördert haben und welche Faktoren waren das?
Aber welche waren es denn? Heißt das jetzt, wir brauchen eine Planwissenschaft und wir brauchen sozusagen so ein gesamtgesellschaftlich vielleicht sogar eben auch staatlich getragen. Ich meine solche Entscheidungen, wie mit diesem Beschleunigungsring, das ist ja so eine Entscheidung innerhalb von einem oder zwei Jahren durchzuführen heißt jetzt, dass im Prinzip entweder alle an einem Strang ziehen oder es zumindest von oben, also so weit oben, wo sozusagen solche Entscheidungen auch finanziell getätigt werden können, es ja eine relativ klare Aufteilung darüber geben muss, was denn jetzt die Zukunftstechnologien oder die Forschungsbereiche sind, in die man investieren will oder sollte oder muss sogar. Was ja wiederum für mich so ein bisschen klingt, als ob sich die politische Ebene an der Stelle sehr viel mehr mit diesen Fragen auch selbst auseinandersetzt?
Während es hier vielleicht sagen wir mal eher der Wissenschaft selbst überlassen wird und nicht so sehr angestoßen wird. Ich meine es ist so ein bisschen so, jetzt habe ich so Kennedy vor meinem geistigen Auge, der meinte, ja wir müssen ja jetzt hier mal zum Mond, weil das ist nämlich total schwierig. Und wir brauchen das sozusagen als kollektive Aufgabe. Wir verstehen das jetzt sozusagen als gesamtgesellschaftliche Anstrengung, das zu machen. Was dann ja auch gemacht wurde und als es dann geschafft war, haben sich alle wieder in den Sonnenstuhl gelegt. Und so einen Eindruck macht so ein bisschen auf mich diese Entwicklung in China. Dass es sozusagen eher eine Frage der gesamten Gesellschaft ist, die das trägt und das bis in die politische Ebene mitbringt, dass sich das sozusagen als Gesamtprojekt versteht? Ist das eine realistische Wahrnehmung oder bilde ich mir das jetzt nur gerade so ein?
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine von der chinesischen Regierung und von sicherlich vielen anderen Regierungen, die eben auf einem anderen Entwicklungsstand stehen als Europa, gewollte Perspektive. Weil sie halt eben auch das Paradigma der Modernität, dessen wo alle hin wollen, eben tatsächlich sehr gut verkörpert. Aber es geht ja hier eigentlich um die Frage sozusagen, die Werte die mit wissenschaftlichen und technischen Entwicklungen kommen, sind sehr stark dadurch bestimmt, wie Europa seinen eigenen Narrativ geprägt hat. Die Frage ist ja, gibt es zum Beispiel eigentlich eine Naturwissenschaft, die nicht gepant ist? Jedes Experiment ist geplant. Ja natürlich hat es ein offenes Ende, aber es gibt ein Planungselement darin. Was macht dieses Planungselement darin? Wie unterschiedlich plant jemand? Und was für eine Auswirkung hat das zum Beispiel auf die wissenschaftliche Entwicklung, ob man zum Beispiel sehr kleinteilig plant, sehr großteilig plant.
Das sind ja Fragen, die wir zum Beispiel in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte bisher nie gefragt haben. Weil das Paradigma der Wissenschaftsgeschichte ist, Wissenschaft muss kreativ, open ended, der Held der einsame Held, der tatsächlich sozusagen Galileo, ein Newton, der alleine auf die Idee gekommen ist. Was die Wissenschaftsgeschichte in Europa heute auch ganz klar sagt, nicht der Fall war. Es gibt eigentlich sehr sehr wenige Einzelhelden und es gibt eben sehr sehr wenige völlig losgelöste Entwicklungen. Sondern die meisten Entwicklungen sind generisch, die meisten Entwicklungen sind tatsächlich auf vielen Vorentwicklungen basierend. Die ersten echten Durchbrüche sind oft rhetorische Durchbrüche, aber nicht faktische wissenschaftliche Durchbrüche. Und ich glaube, hier kann die Wissenschaftsgeschichte im nichteuropäischen Raum einfach wirklich auch diesen anderen Blick zeigen.
Auf was man vielleicht auch schauen muss, was die europäische wissenschaftliche Entwicklung vielleicht auch irgendwie hatte. Wie zum Beispiel das Planungselement. Aber auf das man nie geguckt hat, weil es eben einfach nicht der Narration, dem Ideal einer modernen Wissenschaft entspricht. Darauf wollte ich eigentlich so ein bisschen hinaus. Und dann ist natürlich auch die Frage, wenn man sich die moderne Entwicklung in so einem Land wie Asien oder Indien anguckt, die eben sehr stark geplant ist, wo zum Beispiel, es ist ja immer noch ein open ended Enterprise, weil man ja trotzdem nicht weiß, was hinten rauskommt. Aber wo man eben auch ganz kritisch seine eigenen Wertigkeiten hinterfragen kann und aus denen muss es da eigentlich Dinge ablaufen, die man in dem Blick holen muss. Also die man nicht negieren darf, nur weil sie eben diesem Ideal nicht entsprechen.
Sie haben vorhin selber gesagt, wenn man tatsächlich als Asienreisender so ein bisschen nur unterwegs ist, selbst als Tourist, dann sieht man eben, dass da Dinge passieren, die in Europa oder ich würde sogar sagen, im Westen, was immer das ist, in der westlichen Welt oft unterschätzt werden. Und da ist tatsächlich ein echter Nachholbedarf, da sollte man sich nicht – ich will keine Ängste schüren – aber da sollte man tatsächlich nicht glauben, dass man sich einen Platz geschaffen hat und den tatsächlich auch immer halten wird.
Was kann man denn so den, besonders jungen, aber nicht nur jungen Wissenschaftlern empfehlen? So eine kleine Asienreise? Was sollte man sich anschauen? Was sollte man vielleicht auch für wissenschaftliche Kooperationen und Austausche anstreben?
Ich natürlich würde sagen, man sollte im Blick behalten, dass die Welt wirklich global ist und dass nicht alles da passiert, wo man selber gerade ist. Also es passieren viele Dinge, je nachdem in welchen Disziplinen Sie sich bewegen, auf ganz unterschiedlichen Teilen der Welt. Wir haben jetzt nicht über Südamerika zum Beispiel gesprochen. Da passieren andere wissenschaftliche  und technische Entwicklungen, die aufgrund der sozialen und ökonomischen Umstände dort einfach, Medizin zum Beispiel in Südamerika, die Entdeckung neuer Entwicklungen. Die einem tatsächlich einfach den Blick eröffnen. Und ich glaube, jungen Wissenschaftlern würde ich raten, einfach da hin zu gehen und sich das tatsächlich auch mal anzuschauen. Für Kooperationen würde ich tatsächlich sagen, auf Augenhöhe begegnen ist sehr wichtig.
Viele der wirklich fantastischen Wissenschaftler, die sich in der asiatischen Region bewegen, in der ich mich auskenne, sind auch durch die Globalisierung der Medien eben mindestens genauso weit, wie die Europäer und die Westler und können sich auf Augenhöhe bewegen und man wird viele viele interessante Dinge entdecken, wenn man sich dem öffnet.
Ja. Dann können wir damit eigentlich auch ausklingen mit der Empfehlung, sich doch auch mal die andere Seite des Planetens, also auch die andere Seite des Planetens anzuschauen. Ich meine der Blick ist immer sehr in Richtung Westen, vor allem natürlich in den Forschungsstand USA gerichtet, was viele Entwicklungen betrifft. Nicht grundlos. Ich denke, gerade die USA haben in den letzten 50-60 Jahren einfach es auch hervorragend verstanden, attraktiv zu sein und immer wieder frische Ideen rauszubringen. Die Vormachtstellung, die die USA gerade in der digitalen Entwicklung da gezeigt haben in den letzten 20 Jahren ist sicherlich eine Konsequenz davon und ja jetzt wird es spannend, zu sehen, wenn die asiatischen Länder nachziehen und sie geben sich ja alle Mühe, wie dann sozusagen der Ruhm verteilt wird.
Auf jeden Fall. China wartet auf seinen nächsten Nobelpreisträger.
Ja Frau Schäfer, vielen Dank für die Einblicke hier in die Wissenschaftsgeschichte Asiens.
Bitte, hat viel Spaß gemacht.
Ja mir auch. Und ich hoffe auch allen Zuhörern hat es auch wieder neue Eindrücke gegeben hier rund um unsere Betrachtung der Wissenschaftswelt. Und ich sage, tschüss und bis zum nächsten Mal. Und ja geht bald weiter bei Forschergeist.